Hello, hello, hello, hello, before we go on to the
introductions of everything, we're going straight into it.
Wow, they're like, you gotta go live now.
It's like, live now?
What do you mean live now?
Because we can't miss out on DJ Chatterbox.
Buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, buh, oh, my God.
Thank you for the 50 gifts and check.
Oh, stop, thank you.
Oh, buh, buh, buh.
Fuck, that is loud.
Really loud.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
What a way to start.
I don't know if we have to skip some stuff because they're
like, we're supposed to worry about 10 minutes.
You start this video.
I was like, well, I.
Anyway, I was like, thank you for the 50 gifts and subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, Ambrium, Shadow, Mundane, stop, thank
you for the Twitch Prime and Tier 1 sub, thank you, thank
you.
Alright, let me lower this down.
Anyway, before we get, huge shout out and thank you to Guys
with Victory Nike for today's sponsor.
Today is a very, very special sponsor.
Not like the usual sponsors that you see me do, because I
am, I will be performing in their very special VTuber Arc
Idol Night TNT Star Fan Concert!
Yeah!
It's 3D!
So, for those who didn't know, I'll talk more about it
there, but it is to celebrate the 3.5 anniversary of Niki.
To join us and to cheer.
And this whole thing is apparently a spotlight on Anis and
her journey on becoming an idol.
So it portrays her resilience and growth within the arc's
dark, unforgivable world.
And choosing to confront her long-standing regrets.
for humanity delivering and defining peak performances
against all odds because she used to be an idol so this is
an idol concert now uh so join us to cheer and celebrate
anise today by downloading the game and you get up to 130
pulls and four ssr nike's for free yes for free guys we all
love free stuff um and the concert exclusive code which is
anise idol night to get additional rewards so click on the
link pinned in my chat uh yeah 130 pulls with four ssr nikis
make sure you're a free player if you're a free player that
is good uh we all love free stuff and if you're a new player
that means you can get four ssr nikis for free as a new
player too right off the bat uh go dj chatterbox boom boom
boom boom all right i gotta uh all right sound guy i did
down it a little bit More, even more.
But, but, but, but, but, but, but, but, what else?
What else?
I'm not sure.
But, yes, this is a celebration of a niece.
So, this whole concert is dedicated to her.
There is an emote, a limited edition emote that will be
removed tomorrow.
So, use as much as you can right now, which is the Nike, the
Jokey Bird Nike emote that you can use right now.
Also, sound guide.
The audio might jump all over the place, so if you need me
to up it up or down, let me know.
um what else but yes i am performing in this concert i was
very surprised when they approached me i was an emergency
backup for it so i have to learn and record all of this in a
very super tight deadline i never saw the finished product
so i am reacting to it i'm going in blind with you guys i
never saw like i never heard like my finished mix for all of
this so it's gonna be a surprise for
so i was working on this alongside um alongside the uh my
other concert as well so oh i'm very nervous i am very very
nervous right now um um but i i know it's gonna be awesome
though i know i saw like the outfit they made for me uh
because we all have like each unique outfit to perform uh
for this concert and it looks really sick I okay it's pretty
funny I yeah I have a special outfit for this too um but uh
yeah so I'm super excited to see what they did uh with
everything like I said I had to like I had like two to three
days to record everything for this concert because I was
like a lot a sub in um so um I hope I do okay compared to
everybody else because everyone else that are like really
talented singers really talented performers and then there's
me so i'm a little nervous on how that's gonna look like so
i'm really nervous on how i would look like compared to all
the other all the other uh vtubers here participating in
this concert so i i don't know where i'm at where when i
start like i don't know where i am in the set list guys so
i'll be like is that gonna be is that v it's not me is that
oh it's not if it's me yeah oh we'll know when it's me um
but let me see if there's anything else i'm missing a little
bit of context for those who have never played nike before
so god of this victory nike is a high quality immersive
anime sci-fi RPG shooting game that you can play for free uh
on pc and mobile yes for free and we all love free stuff.
There's a bunch of things going on.
There's a find Doro activity.
So you do exclamation point find Doro.
Keep an eye out for Doro popping up on screen.
So if you spot it, take a screenshot or snap a pic and post
it on Twitter using exclamation point Nikki anniversary or
TT Star fan concert for chance to win a $50 Amazon gift
card.
Yes, $50.
We are picking two winners.
Let's cheer for Anise and the idols together.
There's a lot of new updates.
Looking forward to go DJ Chatterbox Jammo while I do my
talking coins.
While I chill.
Go DJ Chatterbox.
Go, go.
What else?
There was something I wanted to talk about.
But there is a new story event called Star Anise.
It's super important.
for NikiKami is giving us a core details about Nisa's story
and what happened with TV Star and so much more.
So like I said she was an idol before becoming a Niki.
So there's a new story called The Pretty Star Side Story.
And apparently it's a really good story.
You guys want to check it out in-game in the new Niki right
now.
And what else?
So there also is an original new song that released
yesterday called All Eyes on Me.
So you I've seen the dance preview that uploaded on Twitter,
YouTube, on Twitter, YouTube, and TikTok.
That was where the songs, what the song is.
All eyes on me.
And so, yeah, there's the original song.
And then there's Be My Star.
It is also coming out on April 30th.
Let's see.
Well, so there's also new chapters.
There's a huge update.
It is 3.5.
I'll bring it a tiny bit for the shilling.
You're right.
They got a huge shill.
Sorry, DJ's chatterbox.
I will have to say, I was very nervous.
I want to tell you guys this, but ever since I uploaded the
girlfriend cover, I've got a lot of music opportunities.
I was so surprised.
The girlfriend cover, I literally did that as a last minute
thing.
Because, like, for this, you're like, oh, we heard your
song, Girlfriend, so we're really...
want to work with you after that and i was just like oh like
i was so surprised because like i did that i record i did
that song within a month by the way it was a last minute
decision because i was like what do i do for my birthday
like i was like i'll just make a cover i'll just release the
cover i tell you guys it was literally a last minute thing
because i didn't know what to do for my birth for oh wait
not for my anniversary stream i didn't know what to do for
my anniversary stream so now i was like you know what i'll
do a cover song girlfriend because i and you guys like
hearing me sing that song during like the maid cafe and uh
during karaoke so I was just like you know what like it
let's make a cover video of it and then I ended up getting
so many music opportunities because I guess they're like
wait she can actually sort of sing and I don't know I'm to
be fair my mixers really help salvage my vocals so um okay
So, I was very surprised with how many singing opportunities
I got because of the girlfriend cover.
Like, a lot of people would be like, oh, we just listened to
your girlfriend, so I want to, want you to do a cover of
this song, or like, an original, like, I want you to cover
this song, or that song.
And I was like, me?
What do you mean?
Me?
Yeah.
But I just, please, I, I'm, oh, okay.
Oh, my God, 16 seconds, guys.
Let's go!
That's a huge shout out again to Nikkei for sponsoring.
Inviting me to participate in such a cool event!
I really didn't expect myself to see myself doing...
Be participating in like a huge official concert too.
I was very surprised.
Alright, we're starting.
Thank you DJ Chatterbox for the opening act!
Oh, mushy mushy.
Oh, I got to raise up the volume here.
Oh, there's Shy Lily.
Oh, yeah, the host is Shy Lily and Siren.
Yeah.
No, um, Anise just did that.
Yep.
She just saved the Ark.
Oh, my God.
You know, just casually.
Okay.
Siren, we need to do something for Anise.
Something to show her how much we love and appreciate her.
That's right.
Uh-huh.
Get all the idol commanders together and put on a special
art.
Did she say get all the idols?
That's the- I'm the knight!
Like, who invited this girl?
All right, see you later.
Get all the idols?
Who invited this bro?
Who invited bro?
Idol Knight TT Star Fan Concert.
Yes, yes, everyone!
Welcome!
Who's ready for some entertainment?
I am!
How about that opener?
Oh my god.
Okay, there's gonna be a little pattern you're gonna see
with each performer.
And then someone's gonna break that pattern.
I wonder who.
I will see if you can see the pattern.
Why do you assume it's me?
Guys, I said someone.
It might be someone else.
Place that bet right now.
I just need to say, Shaila Lee, your Cinderella cosplay is
perfect.
I'm talking now.
Go to Polly.
Young cosplay is killing it.
It's absolutely fantastic.
Wait, wow.
Look at this crowd that's built up while we got distracted.
China's already going the same.
Let's do a bet.
Who breaks the padding?
That's how confident.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's like, she's baiting.
She's trying to bait us.
Let's do a prediction.
All right, you guys are in it.
of this crowd that has come out for anise i think we're
beyond capacity here we also let anise just did on the arc
white broadcast she saved the arc and so we decided for one
night only and you guessed it that night is tonight that you
most likely all remember last year's silent call right there
you go that's right don't let her fool you she's just she's
bluffing so tonight we are back with more idols and more of
our latest songs that's me she said it she backsees and
he'll take backsees
a secret oh yes there is a surprise guest for a niece let's
get these I want to thank you for inviting 10k hot dog I'm
not as far into Nikki's story but wow this cube is a big
thing catching up a lot on the lore of the story and from
what you've told me about anise's journey it's all so wow of
course sarin i mean anise's story is i'm out to disappear a
little bit give me a sec i gotta fix something but it's okay
i just had to double check something real quick i mean look
at all the commanders we've gathered here tonight commanders
we know you've been following anise's journey you already
know anise has been through a lot and now she's an idol her
journey began many many years ago when she was the twinkle
in our eye on her idol journey with tt star but it was cut
short when she chose to retire and left her idol career
behind anise gave it all up for the ark commanders she chose
to yeah but now she can live forever she can be an idol for
the rest of her life and now we're here she was she was
playing the long game guys yeah cuz like an idol has like
like a shelf period but now she can be an idol forever she's
so smart.
That sounds like a nightmare.
It's her passion.
And this, this is our way of giving back to Anise and
showing her just how much she means to us.
She is.
That's right.
She can live all her competition.
Her idol era.
Yeah.
So we thought if Anise is going to become the brightest star
in the art, a place where stars don't shine.
She deserves a proper debut celebration and not just any
run-of-the-mill debut either no no no no no no no no no not
a chance not on my watch so we answer the call the vtuber
idol commander for here and we're talking full on our wide
vtuber idol fans answer we of course need to thank nikki for
Yippee!
I'm part of it too!
All about Anise and her journey!
We wouldn't just invite the VTuber Commandos here to wave
lightsticks.
That's your job, Commandos.
With the VTuber Ark Idol Night, TG Star fan concert, and all
the banner music of Niki, we thought, hey, why not have the
VTuber Commandos perform too?
That's me!
will be performances of the song you know and love from the
meekin music studio level nine there will be some fan
favorites and some new hits you've never heard before i can
say i can say that right yeah you sure can and you wanna
know why why because this is a fan concert thrown by us for
her!
Yay!
Commanders!
We cannot get this started without you.
We need to see the love for Anise right now!
Anise!
Spam your light sticks if you're here for Anise!
Yeah!
And one of the light sticks yellow, so technically it's for
me too.
If you think about it.
Oh wow, okay, yeah.
I'm like a footnote.
And Doki.
Wait, it's literally my fansticks.
It's literally the one that we're using right now.
It's literally my animated emo.
So technically, this is a fan concert for me.
If you think about it.
So tonight, we're not just watching performances from...
the vtuber idol commanders we are celebrating anise and her
story and her journey yeah doki doki and anise doki okay
enough talking are you ready yeah yeah just got word from
production we are a go let's go Get this party started!
Commanders, get on your feet, get your light sticks and doro
emoji ready!
Turn your volume up and let's start the show!
Yeah!
I don't know, TT Star fan concert!
Starting now!
Alright, I have no idea when I'm starting.
Uh...
I have no idea when I'm starting, by the way.
So we're gonna find out together.
Yay!
I sure did.
Yes,
my T.T.
Star fan concert is- Doki?
Doki Bear?
A VTuber idol commander.
You know her, you love her.
Doki Bear?
Performing- Doki Bell?
Oh, yeah, that's the new one.
Wait, they said Doki Bird, right?
It was a little typo.
Not Doki.
Yeah, what a weird way to say Doki Bird, guys.
It's so weird.
Maybe she stumbled onto it.
She stumbled her words or something.
Oh
Oh, is that that niece's costume?
Oh, I look at the short hair.
Oh, it's loud
I lowered it a bit
Their eyes are up there Oh
Oh, wait, she has her fan mascot on your head.
That's cute.
She has a chat on her head.
She's performing.
She brought her chat.
I didn't bring you guys.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
What?
Where is us, Joki?
Sorry, I didn't know you got checked in.
You weren't allowed to ask security.
I tried guys and confiscated you guys at security I was busy
that day anyway
Sorry some of you guys are like bad at airport.
You're on the no-fly list like what can I say?
I will say
the song they gave me is like very different from the other
songs I will I'll give you guys a little hit I was not
expecting like the song I was gonna sing
See there's a pattern you guys might notice
There's a pattern
I'll post a let me know sound yet They're hearing this
gorgeous song for the first time her story is so powerful
and familiar A lot of us go through very similar challenges,
doubting ourselves and fighting against the noise all the
time.
So to see how Anise has come back to this after all this
time is just so powerful.
I'm so happy to be here tonight to support her and her
journey.
They're all short?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they're all short and now I'm like eight feet tall.
Oh, this big cosplay is amazing!
You look pretty cute yourself, right?
If I'm opening such a special show for Anise, I had to bring
her energy to the stage.
This outfit hits different.
They all brought their fans.
Well, before we let you go, is there anything you'd like to
share with Anise?
And our commanders gathered here tonight.
Anise, keep shining bright and making your commanders proud.
So many were waiting for this moment, and I hope it's
everything that they dreamt it would be.
We all have your back, Anise, and we can't wait to see how
bright you shine.
The stage is so pretty.
I love the colors.
of us of the stage that's right click on my link pinned in
the chat and then you can experience her new idol story
right now
I didn't ask them if I could upload like just my performance
on YouTube but we'll see we'll see how what they say I just
thought of that today since we're doing it on Twitch only
thank you
Yay What an incredible way to start this night for Anise
Thank you so much Silver Veil for showing your incredible
talent with us And now let's welcome our next beattuber idol
commander Don't keep the energy and momentum up for Anise We
can't say no to that, right commanders?
Let's go Anise Let's grab out your legendary list pillows
And let's get ready to welcome the night Next, VTuber Idol
Commander.
Doki Bird?
This next song is a title song for a very special event.
Yes, my commander.
Here, we not only got this super cute, happy red hood skin,
but...
Doki Bird!
...experience some hijinks.
John Cena?
...you're open to say yes.
That's me, Doki Bird!
Of course, thanks, don't ever go.
ghost plan and it got a bit messy thanks to me and my niece
but in the end rapi finally says it yes commander so
commanders with that we need you to say yes to welcoming
this vtuber idol commander to this day introducing donkey
prey eggs with yes my commander oh donkey eggs Oh my god.
I don't know why people are mispronouncing my name today.
They said Doki Bird, right?
They're getting it right eventually.
Whoa.
See, there's a pattern we're gonna find out soon.
I know, it's very hard to figure out what the pattern is,
guys.
I know.
But I bet if you see the next guest, you're going to see the
pattern soon.
Oh, it's the tails.
Are they all have dolls, babe?
You're right.
It could be tails.
They all have tails so far.
Oh, this song is a ball.
You all have Nike outfits.
Whoa.
How low can she go?
Hey.
Hey, hey, hey
This is a bob though Yeah, I like the melody to this Hey hey
The tracking is really good too.
Like with the hand tracking as well.
The fingers.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Oh so catchy.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
It was so fun performing for Anna's and like all of the
other commanders here tonight you did such an amazing job
what was it like being on the stage tonight you know
performing for a knees and tt the pattern continues the
tails obviously have you guys figured out the pattern yet it
could be anything
long hair oh my god you're so right
two patterns Two eyes?
The heels?
High heels?
It could be anything.
All will be revealed soon what the pattern could be.
The song caught my attention by being so fine and Fepi and
it gave me like the energy of cheering on my friends, which
connected me to Rappi.
Rappi's gone through so much and her backstory is so tragic.
So I wanted to represent her strength tonight on stage.
Well, before we let her go, I had a little flex.
Any special message you'd like to share with Anise on TT
Star?
Yeah, of course.
That's why we're here in the first place, isn't it?
They all have to color white on them.
That's a good prediction.
That's a good guess.
All will be revealed soon, guys.
Thank you again.
I need to remember to up the MC.
Alright.
I up did the MC part.
What an incredible way to start this night, Bernise.
Thank you.
over easy eggs for sharing your incredible talent with us
now let's welcome the next vtuber idol commander dokeybird
who could it be oh why would you do that sarin oh i was
introducing our next vtuber idol commander it's dokeybird
why didn't you just say so there are so many other ways to
introduce our Oh my god, it's gonna be me next.
I bet you guys Get your vacuums ready to go boom This VTuber
idol commander comes from a derelict ship from the surface
and well a much split they cut him yo They're like I became
a deleted scene
They're like we gotta keep the pattern Stop doing that Lost
footage.
I'm in the director's cut, guys.
You gotta get the Blu-ray edition.
You wanna get the Doki cut.
Doki Bird?
V2 Idol Commander Matara Khan?
Doki Khan?
I guess.
Everyone's like mispronouncing my name today.
Oh shit.
Sorry guys.
Wait, Matara brought her momos along.
We don't know though.
We don't know yet.
We both haven't seen the video.
Oh, she's hitting those high notes really well.
She takes off the mask and it's actually Doki Burn
underneath.
Everyone takes off the mask and it's all Doki Burn all
along.
She looks so good in the cosplay too.
It really- it doesn't even look like cosplay.
It really actually fits with her model.
Is there...
Fitting that she also got the ghost song.
No, Matara wanted to sing my song.
And then she got assigned this one.
And I was like, I didn't even get a sign.
I was just a backup.
They're like, here's the sign.
He's
like, I just said yes.
Oh, my God.
Next one has to be me.
I am so grateful to be part of this celebration for our
girl, Addis.
We should be thanking you as one of our idol commanders.
tell us what was it like performing for a new society oh my
god i just realized it's in the order of the graphic oh this
is like wait a minute it's the order of the yeah it's the
order i know technically it could be me is that kind of a
fun and high energy song and honestly i'm the mc did i nail
it was like
what made me land on dorothy Well, I've always loved the
character.
I've always loved her complexity.
What is like I break the what did the pattern was the
graphic and I break the pattern Despite her heart being in
the right place.
She has not Always or ever arrived at the end in the correct
way.
Let's be honest.
She has so so so many layers and you can't help but feel and
empathize That's the pattern with her and she lost
everything truly she just lost every single thing that she
had and yet she just kept moving forward because that was
the only option she had that resilience is really really
truly admirable to a space cockroach like me i want to
embody even more of that resilience in my own life and also
you know her dresses are so beautiful her outfit is so this
outfit actually feels like a matara outfit it doesn't like
feel like a cosplay at all it just and
our commanders gathered here tonight yes anise all of your
strength throughout this whole journey please know that all
of us vtuber idol commanders are here to cheer you on yeah
anise anise for all of you commanders listening right now
please go check out the newest event in game and make sure
to support our girl anise come on anise yes
Of course.
But please keep watching.
A wonderful Commandess will spot the hidden Doro during
tonight's show.
Ooh, we'll see them skid-daggle.
Yes, Commandess, you heard us right.
Somewhere, sometime.
Oh yeah, did you guys see Doro?
A hidden Doro will appear, and it is up to you to spot them.
24 hours is now on the clock.
Make sure to post your screen caps or clips to social-
Exclamation point find Doro!
Actually, I don't know.
I'm- I've been distracted a little bit.
On the line.
Win an Amazon or Google Play gift card.
So- She's right there!
Hey, hold on!
You snapshot the Doro to my left and be like, she's right
there and then link it.
There it is.
Wait, I have an idea.
What if I like...
I believe our next YouTuber, Idol Commander, is ready.
It'd be like...
Wait.
Guys!
Guys, I found it!
Guys, screenshot the...
Screenshot doesn't send it.
There it is.
Did you see it?
A trap.
I will make sure a dragoon wins that gift card.
I'm rigging the competition.
Oh my god, there it is.
So subtle.
Whoa.
Catcher if you can.
I'll make sure one of us gets paid.
Did you see it?
The monk who joined the story at our third anniversary.
Where is it?
Don't worry.
Oh, where did he go?
Oh.
Technically, it could be Doki.
She is yellow.
Whoa!
What happened with this song?
This is from the other anniversary thing.
That was from...
We heard this song before.
In the last Niki sponsor stream.
The pattern continues.
Yeah, because they're all they're all wearing the Nikkei
cosplay
Guys, did you catch the Doro?
Like I think I saw it just now.
I think I just saw the Doro
No one said I can't bring the competition It wasn't in my
briefing You
should This song really fits here The voice really matches
well with this
Yeah, this song goes hard
Whoa The little squeak at the end Whoa
I will say I definitely got the easiest
I did Listening to this so far.
I definitely got the easiest
You'll understand.
You'll understand
Please don't get mine you look amazing all right thank you
so much guys
glad the wheels on the bus go up and down up and down up and
down the nikki's on the bus go up and down oh hey oh my gosh
performing hurricane goal she carries so many lives and
perspectives within her and I wanted to reflect that depth
on stage.
The calm, the fortitude to withstand it all, and everything
in between.
Being here tonight for Anis and all the commanders just made
it even more meaningful.
Guys, let's keep trying to...
Right, they said we invited idol VTubers.
There's no takebacks, these guys.
It's already written in video.
But they invited me.
I might have been planned C or D.
but I said yes I'm in it in the end in the end I'm still
part of the constant
yeah our next youtuber auto commander they come from the
surface where they've been wandering for a very very long
time with one mission in mind kill the queen tied to the
goddess fall starline and a familiar When you boot up Miki
is...
Doki Bird?
This song is an incredibly beautiful...
Oh my god, it's a Doki?
Originally performed by Prennel to drive home the emotional
toll that Snow White was forced to endure.
This next song is so much beautiful.
I cannot wait to hear it come to light.
Oh wow, they spelled my name wrong.
They put an M instead of a D.
Which is understandable.
The M is next to the D.
It's none other than Michi Mochidi, the set of memory.
That's right!
You all lost the prediction!
I didn't break the pattern!
That's right!
I told you!
That's a key, Ray!
You didn't believe it!
Oh, this is from claiming my point.
I know what's under this.
We don't know what's under.
She's not taking it up.
Also, this is very pretty.
It's very pretty.
She sings really well here.
Like, she even, I don't know if she's harmonizing with
herself.
Or if she does the main melody.
But the harmony sounds like her.
But it's so high.
Oh my god, yeah, she did amazing.
That is such a high song.
Like I said, I definitely got the easiest.
I got the easiest song.
Fuck yeah.
And I still got paid for it.
Oh, thank you.
What was it like to sing this incredibly emotional...
See, she didn't have to take it off.
All of the commanders and amuse at this fan concert.
Still on.
It was a beautiful song.
It hits you somewhere, man.
It hits you somewhere deep.
And getting to carry that song onto the stage tonight.
all of you commanders and especially for you anise i poured
everything i had into it and i hope no that's just her hair
clipping guys that's dope guys she broke the pattern what
about anise's idol journey stands out to you what inspired
you to sing tonight for all of us here so what really gets
me about anise is that she walked away from her dreams she
just left the stage and left all these pressures and
expectations behind and I think that takes a lot of strength
to recognize and you know what now she's back she is someone
who is just so resilient and coming back to all this I think
that takes so much courage and now here she is coming back
to it what's the pattern stronger than ever that's what
inspired me to be here tonight We all know what the pattern
is.
And I just wanted to be one of them.
Now, before we let you go, do you have any special words of
encouragement or messages for Amuse and the members of the
TT Star?
Annis, you beautiful, beautiful star.
She's wearing a helmet.
That's the pattern.
Every YouTuber idol commander who stood on that stage, we
are all here.
She's the first one to wear a helmet.
Guys, see, she broke the pattern.
No one else wore a helmet until her.
A headgear.
See?
Now, everyone else had goggles on until Michi.
She broke the pattern.
No headgear.
Oh my god, who is the next?
away from the outer realm whoa who could it be who could it
be well with the latest character story event focusing on eh
you know this wonderful theme is coming in hot yes i'm so
excited anise anise our next performer will be helping us
tell the story of eh or oh my god deep lore about E.H.
and her origins tied to Elisa.
Heavenly Father?
And then Heaven gave commanders some incredible Nikkei
storytelling and expanded the story of Chibi-Doki?
Who could it be?
But also heavenly ascension and the early days of the Outer
Rim.
Let's give it up for our Outer Rim VTuber Auto Command.
Oh my god!
Cheapy bird
It's her Also you can't say I break the pattern Because look
at this
I got some Augmentation I got I got
I got some enhancers.
Is that a bummer?
You have to see me.
God, I'm so cool.
At least a sea cup.
And I just start crumping.
How low can I go?
I told you I got the easiest song.
Two verses, fab, I'm done.
Just dance now.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Bum, boom, boom, the bass drop.
Bum, bada, bada.
Let him go.
Yeah.
Now I just dance.
God, I'm so cool.
Yeah!
That's right!
Let's go!
Cinema.
That's me.
So cool!
Okay, wait, first of all, that song is an absolute banger!
Okay!
Okay, Pastoki was so cool!
And I did not miss!
Getting to perform that live and turn up- You mean the
pattern?
This is why I couldn't bring you guys to the airport.
I'm still buzzing!
I could either get a C for it or...
I hope I made you
poor stuff to get dressed.
You, uh, you really took the EH cosplay to the next level,
huh?
Okay, listen.
If you're gonna show up, friendlies, you gotta show up.
What happened, Preston?
Why was Pat Stokey so cool?
He just had to step anything and neither do I.
She was strapped and ready to take down anything standing in
her way.
Which honestly the most relatable energy when it comes to
protecting the people you care about and out of all of that
EH has a deep love for the out rim.
It's people.
It's all love and protecting those near her Is that also
kind of Anis's whole deal?
I hope Anis hears our songs and I was like Anis anise
anise's anise.
I Keeps blurring together for me I Thank you, don't give a
word.
What if I say it all?
One of them would be right.
What?
I don't, commanders.
I think it is time.
Time for us all to come together to make sure Anius truly
hears us tonight.
What do you have planned, Silvery?
Well, I think it's time to come out with one more new song a
song that anise wrote and performed with tt star surely with
this final song she will hear us all and know just how much
she means to the ark and everyone else yeah all our vtuber
auto commanders have already sung tonight and they've used
that's not true i saw it on the graphic
I know there's still one more!
Looks like I got it just in time.
I had a few raptures to take out on the way down here,
but...
They were no match for me.
Oh!
Wait, there's two, Anise?
Let's get this stage ready!
I've got this one, V-Tuber Idol Commanders.
Don't you worry.
This one's for you, Anise.
I told you I didn't break the pad in.
Holy shit!
Her power level!
What does it say?
No, no, I didn't.
I was stacked.
Oh my gosh, she learned Korean.
Wait, did I see a Doro?
Exclamation by Doro, guys.
Amazon gift card
I like this Stella it's very catchy It's definitely very
very catchy
brings this incredible song in bravery and humor to a world
that can feel so bleak and hopeless and her matter-of-fact
steadfast attitude.
It's something I honestly hope to carry in my own life.
And be my star?
Oh my god, I love fun party energy.
It gets any crowd bump in.
And I just wanted to feel like every commander in this room
was singing for Ennis together.
And I hope that's exactly what you all felt tonight.
Belle, you've given us all the energy boost and final push
we needed.
what was it like performing for all the commanders and anise
on this special night okay honestly overwhelming but in the
best way because standing on the stage knowing anise is out
there somewhere knowing all of you commanders are here
because of how deeply you love her i felt every single one
of you with me and performing for being my star for your
niece at her concert for this moment in her journey i didn't
want it to end it's one of those moments I'm gonna carry
with me for a very long time You also chose A very special
cosplay tonight Oh, it's cute Do you maybe want to talk?
Oh yeah, that's her idol outfit, right?
Anisa's idol outfit?
I had to do a super Deep lore dive into her character What I
found out Really, really surprised me I had no idol You
know, as someone who really wanted to be an idol That broke
my heart to hear that it didn't work out for her and uh you
know she lives forever now so she could always come back but
the thing about her was how she didn't let this horrible
tragedy in her life define her i think realizing that your
dreams are not always going to work out is probably one of
the most painful things you'll ever experience but i think
it puts you on the path that you were always meant to be on
and that really goes to show right like anise was able to
make new friends make new memories, start new dreams.
I think that's the kind of resilience that deeply, deeply
inspires me.
Anise Overspec is proof of that.
She shows up full power and she does not stop.
Wow.
I mean, yeah.
I know Anise has definitely heard your voice tonight and
your words of encouragement.
Thank you so much, Baal.
Before we let you go, Baal, Is there any final words of
encouragement you want to give Anise?
Anise, your story reminds every single one of us something
very important.
That your life is your own.
The art tried to shape you.
Fate tried to break you.
But you said no.
You chose who you are.
That's right.
Let's go, Anise.
So step into that spotlight that has always been waiting for
you.
And shine.
We love you.
We are so...
so proud of you and we will keep cheering for you every
single step of the way this is just the beginning and this
is where you're the best yeah i can't believe it and these
gets two cosplays you gathered us all here tonight shadowly
you made this happen oh stop stop it wasn't just me it was
Look at this crowd!
They're all here cheering you on me!
You know, it's a jokie bird.
All parts of the ark.
Yeah, and we couldn't have done it without the support of
Niki.
Level 9 and our amazing...
Thank you again, Niki, for the sponsor!
And for inviting me to this concert.
Honestly, really cool experience.
Never thought I'd be part of something like this before.
Oh yeah, the special guest!
We didn't forget!
She's she's here.
TT Star?
Is it Doki Bird?
Special guest?
Encore!
Doki Bird Encore!
Bad buddy?
Let's come here tonight to show the arc.
what happens
before we exit the stage and let anise and tt star wow you
with their incredible talent we justin beaver he's coming
here after kochella for being part of this very special
night we truly couldn't do this without you thank you thank
you thank you yeah thank you commanders anise hurt us all
because of you
time for anise to shine in the next Chapter of Niki
We're at the rate to raise up the end.
I always forget the MC part
Wait, who are our backup dancing?
Oh my god, this is a true idol concert now
We're literally like the opening act Now the real show
begins Now
Ah, Min and Prika.
You know what's funny?
Um, they showed, like, the lyrics of the other songs.
And I was like, oh, Min's in here.
I didn't realize.
I didn't realize there was a Niche called Min.
And I was like, oh, Min's part of this.
I saw her name in the lyric sheet.
And I realized, wait, but Who the fuck is?
Wait, why is Anise?
Why is she singing with Anise?
Why is she singing with Anise, though?
And I Googled it.
I was like, oh, there's a mint in the kumike.
I was like, damn, she gets to sing with Anise?
I just got a solo sound.
And I told my manager, it was like dokey dot dot he gave me
the dokey dot dot dot
Look, there's so many Nikes!
There's so many Nikes!
I remember Cinderella.
She was my first Nikes.
Well, not my first one.
But my most OP Nikes.
That was it!
Wow!
That was crazy.
That was really good.
I should sort of watch my performance again.
Wait, I'm going to...
I want to see it again.
That was so cool.
It was my first time seeing it.
And it turned out so well.
It turned out really, really good.
All right, here it is.
Let's see.
Oh, my God.
I'm so cool, man.
Holy shit.
I'm so cool.
I'm good.
I'm more So humble What happened to you, Joki?
He used to be so cool That's still me It's the same Joki,
just remember that
I'm so happy I got signed this song.
I literally had like, like, I didn't like two to three days
to record everything.
So thank God.
Thank God I was able to do something.
with it.
It was pretty, I, mine was two or three days because I was
like a last minute, like an emergency sub.
I was an emergency sub.
This is a preview for my concert.
I don't even remember.
The crazy part, this is like two verses and I already forgot
the lyrics.
I was like...
That's why I was like, oh my gosh, thank God I got the
easiest song.
The cat cuts off the blood flow to the spring.
Let's go fast.
I actually had to do like retakes too.
Like I said, I was like so stressed out.
I had to retake like, do like two new retakes.
And they're like, we need it by the end of the day.
And I was like, ah!
God, I'm so cool.
Yeah, the lack of blood flow where it's just all pure
instinct, pure cinema.
Absolute cinema.
All right.
It's not over yet.
There's still a little bit of Nikkei left to go.
But before I, because they want me to check out the
promotional video for the 3.5 anniversary.
But before I show the video, we're going to check out the
link pinned in the chat to cheer and celebrate with Anise
today by downloading the game.
And he can get up to 160 pulls and four SSR Nikkei's for
free.
And we all love free stuff.
And also we have an exclusive code, Anise Idol Night.
And you get additional rewards for it too.
So yay, more free stuff!
Anyway, let's go watch the promotional video.
That's how the entertainment world works, Hansen.
Whoa.
As long as I'm enjoying myself, that's all that matters.
And enjoyment?
It only comes when someone else is suffering.
Oh my god.
Green idol is so high.
to be a star who could bring hope to people i used to think
that if i worked hard enough i'd succeed oh you're poor now
you child yeah that's what i thought not in the
entertainment business let's do our best with the people who
came to see us oh let's hurry and grab something to eat i'm
starving Get some practice in, will you?
You try to slim me down a bit.
Wait, does that mean that Min and Prika also turn into
Nikes?
I think that's pretty funny, wouldn't it?
Damn right, we are.
You were amazing at least, Min, Prika.
I have waited so long for this day.
We did our best.
Oh.
We really did our best.
But did it all go wrong?
There are no stars in this place.
No matter where you look, is darkness oh are you really
gonna give up never give up i used to think that but it
wasn't completely meaningless after all you're just a
minority there are plenty of good people
they can this time i'll definitely make it happen she gets a
duo there
Look at that, see?
Dreams do come true.
She did it, guys.
She did let the haters get to her, guys.
She fucking did it.
And now she'll never die.
She's a Niki now.
She can live forever.
So technically, isn't it?
an improvement yeah she became a forever idol exactly see
it's even better sure like a lot of people died but like
she's immortal but like and she has ptsd now but her dreams
came true
All right, it's time to pull up some Niki and check out the
new stuff for the 3.5 anniversary.
Let me go pull that up.
Sound guy, are you here?
Are you here, sound guy?
I know the other sound guy had to clock out, so don't worry.
I don't know if the other sound guy has started his shift
yet.
So, all right, new sound, the second sound guy is here.
Oh my God, what's my password?
give me a sec I prepped everything but I forgot my is this
no um give me a sec guys it's password time it's one of
these passwords will work alright I should really I should
really write this down like two for the issue is that
instead of keeping one password I keep like multiple
passwords and for some reason I thought that was like a
really smart thing to do just in case you know um just to be
more safe but then the thing is I don't really write which
password goes with which account so it's sort of a little
bit of a little gotcha right now that we're doing uh I wrote
the passwords down but I haven't matched for which account
it is but yeah if you guys didn't know there's a bunch new
stuff that they added for um the 3.5 anniversary there's a
lot of commanders have new ssr uh uh all the times we'll be
able to get four uh ssr nike and 130 pulls for free by
participating in in-game events oh all right give me a sec
sound yeah let me know if i need to be louder or quieter so
i was like i was here first i should be first sound guy
Yeah, but the other sound guy said which was the first to
say how to tune the volume.
Let them fight.
They can't even fight each other.
One is already at somewhere.
One clocked up.
Okay.
All right.
I'm downloading the update right now.
Right.
And there's a new story event.
as i mentioned is about star anise so it's about her her
story about how she was an idol before she became anike and
uh so and also like i said there's some new songs that
release all eyes on me and be my star there's new chapters
chapter 45 and 46 so and new characters and costumes so
anise since she is the star she has a new costume and uh
neon has supervision and a fan favorite a v-star oh my god
holy shit
oh my god all right i was not ready for that i had i
instantly sound guy did not think that was all right there
we go and what else there's also new mini game Tracing the
Stars.
So it's a rhythm minigame where players compete TD Stars
debut stage.
So it basically, let's check out the rhythm.
I want to check out the rhythm game.
We can check out the costumes too.
There's additional new costumes.
Rappy, Dorothy, Liber Leo has a bunch of new costumes.
So Rappy has new idol-themed costume.
Same with Dorothy.
Bum, bum, bum.
Do they have my song?
Does that have enter in?
Actually, let me ask.
it...
I'm asking my manager about it.
I'm updating.
Sorry, I'm downloading the new update for a 3.5 anniversary.
Let us see.
You know it's what the update video is that's why you want
to see it you know exactly what it is there you go show it
now it's gone that's right the animation is done now you
can't see it show us perhaps goddess of victory Nikkei all
right let's pull this up yeah we're gonna we're gonna ask uh
we're asking right now we can upload a video but we need
permission for that i knew i i didn't think about it before
because i i guess like because i didn't see the video so i
was like i don't know what if it's bad what if like mine is
bad compared to everybody else because i just all i knew was
like my raw vocals so i was like really nervous about it
because everyone else were like singers and stuff singers
and performers so i was super nervous compared to like how i
would compare to everybody else so i was like i don't think
i don't i'm not gonna ask about it and now that i saw i was
like oh i actually sort of want this on my channel i i sort
of want like the standalone video on my youtube i was like
wait it's pretty sick wait a minute i'm so cool in this
video like wait a minute i might be pretty cool Let's claim
it.
How are we doing?
Oh, the 3.5 anniversary.
That's right.
Give me all the free shit.
Yay!
Yay, free Avistar.
Yeah, this is a free character that you can get right now.
Look at that.
Yay, free SSR.
Oh, she's cute.
Oh my, there's so much free stuff.
both claim yes please I would like yes what do I click
there's so many oh I gotta claim this claim all right claim
there we go anything else name
claim give me the outpost claim Yay!
Look at all that free stuff.
What's wipeout?
Uh, round up team, equivalent.
Let's fuck it.
Let's go.
Yay!
Alright, what else?
Oh, shit.
No, that's not free.
Get out of here.
You're not free.
Oh, shit, there's more stuff.
Yay!
Look at all the little dots.
Oh, yeah.
up holy shit 100k let's go no free i leave oh my god more
free let's go what else any more dots oh road to villain
okay clean up got more points uh oh yeah free for once a day
where's my free stuff Okay, free.
Empty.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
All right.
What did I get?
It's a free one, so I don't expect much.
All right, get out of here.
You're just scrapped for me.
All right, let's get it.
Wait, do I have enough?
How much do I have?
Oh, I definitely have enough.
Is that?
That's run.
Oh, that's Renice.
All right, let's go.
I should get her.
First try.
Come on.
I was there.
at your concert like i was literally at your concert i
performed for you there's no way oh my god wait wait a
minute oh wait a minute wait a minute no way wait hold on
hold hold oh my god double in these a triple in these
Where's the niece?
Come on!
Come
on!
Oh my god!
Fight, thank you for the 1500 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it.
They painted me with all the other anises.
They're like, oh, you wanted the default anise, right?
Fight and paint it.
the pillar i can't believe it they baited me with the other
anises oh yeah for those who don't know where's my clan i
don't know where my clan is where did i put it is is it here
join my join my clan food files guys join it we have we have
sorry i have to count on my finger you have seven slaps yeah
it's join my guys join it all right it's called food fells
our only rule is that you can't feed your nike's did you
guys change my rule i swear to god where is the rule it's my
union i only have one don't feed the nike's that's my one
rule if you want to join my union and not allow any food all
right i don't think we're gonna get her anymore
I mean, at least I have, like, 20 anises.
I don't even get her default anises.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God, I don't even get it.
I don't even get the default anise.
That's crazy.
You don't even give me that privilege.
They heard you don't feed him.
Oh, wait, wait.
Unless...
Awww.
They shop, don't you know?
Nice.
Nice to meet you.
Okay, I still have, like, one more.
I still have one more.
One last chance.
One more roll.
Awww.
Oh my god.
Look at all those purples though.
Like, oh you wanted a niece?
Here's your niece.
There she is.
There she is right here.
I can use my gems Maybe she'll be here Wait, wait, wait,
wait Obtainable I got an obtainable award Oh, wait, the code
The code, I forgot That's my code Okay How do I claim it
again?
I don't remember
How do I claim it?
The code Where is it?
scroll down the cd key is this some status where the fuck is
oh cd key alright there we go alright what was the code
again oh wait I can look at my anise idle night there you go
redeem now okay I got it I got my free stuff
okay that's nothing to do with okay It's okay.
It's all right.
All right.
Use my gems.
Here you go.
This is it.
I think I only had...
This is my last roll.
Ah.
Doesn't even give me an Anise.
Wait.
Unless...
Maybe I'll get her one by one.
wait unless unless recruit once a day ordinary recruit 10
okay but maybe
i might do have the other tickets i'll fuck you let's just i
might as well maybe i'll get something here
no still purple it's still it's still purple though Maybe
I'll get...
Oh, look, there's Anise.
There's Anise, guys.
I got her.
Why are they all purple?
Wait, maybe again?
No!
Please!
Just when we're gone!
Oh, my God.
It's all purple.
I don't even...
I don't even get an Anise...
Anise for...
good luck i don't even get one for good luck okay but what
if what if guys okay how much do i need how much how much do
i need gem wise technically how much do i need three
thousand okay i think i can make it all right where's the
campaign guys how many do i have to kill to get there where
am i okay it is not becoming to rush I might have enough I
will turn everything into bubble okay my power alright
that's fine this is sad genuine Niki stream I just just one
more pull guys just one more also sound guy is it better now
sound guy the audio is it better oh event login oh shit okay
you're right all right guys finish this and then we're gonna
see we can claim more gems i'll get you to your destination
oh she's gonna get me to that destination guys
wait what were the codes that nikki posted on twitter i need
all of them give me all the codes Let's just cancel it.
It's criminal that I don't even get it.
If I don't get it.
We have arrived at your destination.
It's been a pleasure escorting you here safely.
Yeah.
We gotta use every resources possible.
Alright.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Oh my god.
One of them will give me the Anise.
Get it.
Tap to enter.
All right, claim redeemed successfully.
That's good, guys.
That's good.
That means everybody can use this, too.
See, we try to go and help each other.
We're so helpful.
We're each providing for the community.
Oh, my God.
Look at all these rewards.
All right.
That's good.
Look at all.
Look at that.
Like all that money.
All right, and then the event.
The event apparently gives me free money too.
All right, murmurs and chatters ripple through.
The crowd in front of the Arcadian Hall.
The line snakes outward vanishing into the distance.
I've never seen this many people in one place before.
Do we really have to wait in this line?
Wait, let's do...
auto looks like we'd have to go way back to get mine so why
are we all the way up here it's for the concert our fellow
oh wow please don't put well yeah i was gonna say wow let's
head to the back for now the line's only getting longer come
on can't you pull some strings or something it's not like
we're strangers that's true she is part of my army
Commander, can't you use your authority to do something
about it?
Excuse me, I saved the world multiple times.
I should be allowed in the front.
Long wait.
It would have been nice to at least say hello to me.
I heard that like, um...
You're all here.
Oh, hey, Abyssar.
Hey, Abyssar.
Hi, Neon.
This is where you need to walk.
Commando unit, right?
It's a pleasure to meet you.
I'm Abyssar from the inspection.
unit overseer no way i'm gonna say i heard that um this way
please uh especially in japan you you have like like they
treat everybody equally so like so like because like i was
there was a short that came up where it was basically like
uh they're like oh when you're at disneyland you're not you
have to like line up for everything there's no like like
there's no like uh sort of like skip i thought there was a
fast pass but i don't maybe they implemented fast pass
recently and the shirt was old because they were asking the
staff and was like what if the ceo uh what if the ceo of
disney wanted to uh came over like would you would they have
to line up and they're like yes like yes they have to line
up no she didn't becoming a pop star made her arrogant anise
has been the busiest of us all she probably yeah what if one
disney came back to land like you gotta wait in line i
didn't realize in japan disneyland there's no fast pass oh
she's nervous
don't be scared mrs miss that mustang
very flamboyant mrs miss well i'm such a total newbie
performing in a place this huge is something i've only ever
dreamed of so actually doing it feels completely unreal what
about you mint me i've been dreaming of this moment for as
long as i can remember so i can't wait to get on stage
Nerves ruin such a huge opportunity Good You've got what it
takes to be a star Unlike some people They've been a star
since the day I was born Damn So humble
Rattle, rattle Oh, she's still scared It was all like a
persona she was putting on
She's painting on She's painting on a face What Did you see
vibrating parts on your arms or something?
Uh...
What do I do?
And you, Prika?
It's set in place and her foot tapping along to the beat.
She's ready for anything.
He's just vibing.
She's locked in.
Wee-wee.
Bonjour.
are
you serious you're listening to Buddhist chants mind calm
but she's so locked in focus perform she's a lost cause
ain't she I think they're fucked guys dance
song essence hey snap out of it What are we supposed to do
if you lose your marbles?
Get your act together.
The room falls silent in an instant.
This is Arkion Hall, the biggest stage in the Ark.
Oh, it's in the Ark.
I was gonna say.
People came all this way and spent their money to see you.
Don't make a fool of yourselves.
Being amateurs won't earn you a second of pity here.
Oh my god, wait.
That artwork is so detailed.
Why?
I just noticed it.
Mrs. Miss's art is so detailed.
.
Trolls?
No such luck, Mesetol.
It's time to become real professional.
Metwinkling stars.
He's so full.
French.
Oh, Abby Star is here.
I've brought them for you.
Look, we're all here to support you, Anise.
Let's go!
So, how do I look?
Like a total pop star, right?
You look beautiful.
You look breathtaking.
What?
Really?
Do you always have to say things like that?
Rappy, Neon, you made it.
I was so nervous, but seeing you two totally relaxes me.
I'm still a bit nervous, though.
You?
Nervous?
Why did she bring the gun to a concert?
I feel kind of nervous for some reason.
Is that not like a wrist gun?
Oh, wait, why the fuck did she bring a sword to the concert?
Why?
Protection.
Wait a minute.
We've heard so much about you too.
It's actually a drill.
Does it make it any better?
See the counters on person is kind of surreal.
I figured you'd look like battle-hardened heroes, but I
didn't expect this.
Maybe I should have put on some camel paint.
Ma'am, she has a drill!
At least put on a scary face.
She's literally carrying weapons!
Now that's what I call a battle-hardened hero.
Totally awesome!
Alright everyone, grab a seat!
We still got a bit before the concert- I like that they have
matching bracelets because they're like a group together.
Showtime's in 30, so get yourself together.
Um, I'd feel more at ease if we stayed together.
You're all you need on stage.
them along whoa miss miss but good to see you i guess we
should grab our seats before before they're all gone later
later you guys we're gonna put on one hell of a show
honey is this your special day
let's do this all right let's roll on it I have like little
animal mascots so that for marketing reasons.
Let's light it up!
Oh!
Anise!
Star!
Yay!
Star Anise!
They're smart.
They know the mascots go hard.
I love the logos.
Very cute.
I'm not nervous at all.
Oh, I'm not performing yet.
Okay, login stamp.
Don't tell me you're nervous too.
We gotta grab the money.
Oh, login.
Okay, advanced recruit voucher.
We need that.
Okay, we got two of that now.
Star and niece.
What's staff?
Oh, that's the big challenge area.
What else gives me new stuff?
Does story give me new things?
Where am I?
I- Mission the shop?
Okay.
Oh, it's our new magazine cover.
That's cute.
Okay, reward info.
Avistar.
Enter.
Oh!
Oh, okay, so we have to have a new Spreka mint.
Oh, that's so cute.
Wait, I like it.
It's like themed around...
It's themed around the...
Okay, my power level is pretty weak.
Come back.
I'm...
Let's rock and roll!
Wait, they're so weak.
I'm all...
Are you...
I really do enjoy being with...
Alright, there you go.
It's like themed around...
around like a idol group.
Let's light it up.
Hi.
Are we...
Is it break time?
Wait, what does clicking them do?
Alright, let's go.
Her heart hammering in her chest.
She glances back.
Her eyes meet Mint and Preakas.
Then she looks even further.
Moose dying is staring straight at her.
Beyond him.
the path she walked.
Memories of her time with the counters of moving between the
surface and the arc surged forward.
She looks even further back and suddenly her first
performance flashes before her.
Alright.
Today was our very first stage performance.
The first time we finally got to show what we've been
working on to an audience of 20.
We got on stage saying danced and then it was over what do
you mean what there was a line for now anyway what do you
mean 20 was there not a line so oh this is a flashback okay
before okay okay this is a flashback so that's your excuse
for all those mistakes i thought they just changed clothes
probably just i was like i was in the clothes we used to
before first performance isn't cute It just makes you look
like an idiot.
Hey, you're one to talk.
20 is pretty good for a first performance.
Not gonna lie.
It's like in the first stream.
It's your very first stream and 20 people showed up.
That's pretty good.
You couldn't remember the formation and we're just standing
there like a deer in headlights.
So I gave you a little nudge.
I wasn't just standing there.
I was interacting with the fans.
What fans?
We don't have any.
There's no way.
Oh, she at first sight.
She doesn't believe that you don't care about the
performance.
If you wanted all the fame for yourself, you should have
become a comedian.
Damn, she's so Debbie Downing.
Why didn't you just become a trainer?
Hey, hey, chill out, you guys.
I know everyone was nervous since it's our first
performance, but let's not go pointing fingers at each
other.
of people that's nothing we can't fix next time ladies
ladies so cut it out with the bickering okay anise have you
even been practicing why was your singing so bad wow you
were smiling so much it looked kind of creepy i nearly
jumped when i saw you next to me whoa you were moving really
breakup marionette you were saying hi earlier right you
weren't flipping them off or anything were you guys i don't
think this group is gonna work out guys the chemistry might
not be it just stay still it'll at least show you're trying
you little i'm trying to be nice wait why are y'all getting
up on our knees yeah i'm practicing will you and try
slimming down a bit whoa and i'm supposed this is why
they're the backup dancers but who do it This is exactly why
they're the backup dancing.
The concert said, the concert said, let's go a niece.
Not let's go pre-commit and a niece.
They started at first.
You're done with the talk.
They're backup dancers to me.
So, what's the result?
Yeah, what's their problem?
Why don't we talk on the way back to the office?
Hansen.
Mr. Manager, man.
You know what backup dancer is everyone's a backup dancer to
a niece in my eyes The central government has banned private
car use Cars registered before the ban are fine, but
registering a new one is practically impossible unless
you're very high up So you're a big shot, huh?
No way this car was registered a long time ago Since
registration is tied to the vehicle itself cars registered
today are going for astronomical prices so how much would
this go for now i've never really thought about selling it
but it's probably worth more than 10 times what it
originally sold for oh my then if we sold this we could get
a new office that's true i don't think so uh best it covers
some renovations then sell it no then how about selling just
one tire That way we'd at least be able to fix the showers.
How are we gonna drive the car?
The water's dripping like pour over coffee.
No.
This belonged to my mother.
Oh.
This is an old-ass car, I guess.
Well, that got awkward fast.
Um, sorry.
No, no.
I didn't mean to make it awkward.
That's on me.
But there's an even bigger reason I'm not selling this car.
bigger than they belonging to your mom right like this
that's a picture-perfect moment fair enough so how do you
feel about your first performance you saw it didn't you I
think it was good good my ass it was full of mistakes the
audience hardly reacted and we ended up fighting afterward
what they say did we get a regular slot hmm no they turned
us down can I ask why what do you mean why because our
performance sucked freaka holy shit calm down freaka oh my
god they didn't say it's good either it wasn't that bad wow
wow Thanks for the heartfelt pep talk.
Damn, who heard her?
Uniqueness?
Everything you've done is just covers of pretty songs.
Friendly fire is crazy.
We're in a fiercely competitive era for pop stars.
Since almost all of them are just copying pretty.
That's right.
She's keeping it real.
Like no hope at all.
Pretty was a shock to the Ark in more ways than one.
A star like that doesn't come around often.
After Pretty was gone, many people became Nikkei's.
Oh, no.
Under Tetra, dreaming of stardom.
Dreaming of becoming the next Pretty.
Their songs, their dances, even their personas were modeled
after Pretty.
they mean when they say we're not unique so we're just
another bunch of pretty wannabes oh my god they're all like
that i'm gonna become a niki what do you mean they decided
to join the war just to be a next celebrity more precisely
it's risky for a single company to control so many nikes to
keep this in check any yeah screw it was join the military
under the central government They're free to act as they
wish, but must follow orders if the government issues one.
Only the truly exceptional are directly managed by Tetra.
As a result, offices have sprung up everywhere, brimming
with hopeful Nikes chasing their dreams.
As much as I hate to- It became a Nike just to be an- Okay,
a little bit of priorities are a little screwed, a little
bit like...
Skewed a little bit.
No choice but to go all in on originality.
many pop stars have like you want to save the world
naturally the competition or do you want to be famous
composers and songwriters is intense and we're not in any
position to take part in it because we're broke see you
thank you for the twitch prime they could thank you money we
hardly have any name recognition either hmm some Nikes don't
get out go out to war oh my god wait do they like is a
choice or is it like a draft system we've got no money no
connections aren't you ashamed of letting talent like ours
rot in this dump of an office not at all i'm completely fine
well we're not it's more what they can use you for so our
first depends on who made you so you're useless and then
like oh it depends on the company okay hopefully that's the
only time Let's hurry and grab something to eat.
Like, what's the most useless Nikkei job you can get?
Step on it.
All right, all right.
Since that didn't work out, let's go get some food.
Yeah, no, you get sent into the meat grinder.
With all that money, isn't like the mailman?
Imagine you were like, you're like, I'm gonna sign up to be
a Nikkei.
So I can help save the world.
And then they put you in the mailroom.
They put her like, I'm ready.
I'm ready to make a difference in life.
And then you become an immortal mailman.
Mail is important.
I don't think they sign up to be the mailman, no.
One more victory for both of me.
It's so stuffy here.
Oh, no.
They forgot to leave the windows open before leaving.
Tetra's entertainment, Ellison's services, Missilis is
security in broad strokes.
Outrunning errands for work.
There's food in the fridge.
Oh, so it basically, basically they fuck up the conversion,
the conversion, uh, conversion process.
You're just, you're just going to be the immortal mailman or
DoorDash.
Maybe we should come along too.
Ellison is military.
Okay.
Putting ourselves out there.
So you would want to sign up for Tetra.
want to get drafted into the war i agree we're not the
world's greatest i assume like they would have the most i
assume tetra would have the most way to protect uh most sign
ups on the way here didn't i there are so many pop stars
dreaming of becoming the next pretty that we're in what you
might call a fiercely competitive era to secure a regular
gig land an advertising deal or even appear in a single
scene of a tv show you can imagine how much maneuvering goes
on behind the scenes there are countless ways to promote
yourself but the kinds that sponsors actually prefer aren't
that many I don't need to spell out which ones do I that's
why I protect you all get famous and then we'll be the ones
calling the shots until then just hang in there now eat and
get some rest I'll Yay!
He's not one of those...
Those...
Bad managers.
The scummy ones.
He's actually looking out for them.
That's nice.
It's not one of those words...
What's it called?
Those managers that take advantage of celebrities?
Or take advantage of up-and-comers?
Seems like a good guy.
Towers have already passed, but she barely...
She watches herself in the mirror, going over every step in
expression again and again.
Oh, that's a cute outfit.
I wish today had gone a little better since it was our first
performance.
The sound was off and the stage setup left a lot to be
desired.
But what disappointed me most was our performance.
Honestly, it was terrible.
Whoa!
Hey, don't be so harsh.
It's your first performance.
You're not...
It's never...
It's not going to be perfect.
Hmm.
Maybe as early as tonight.
Who knows?
Boss might have something for us.
Like he said, pop stars are everywhere these days.
She might be...
She might be a downer.
Damn.
That outfit, though.
Honestly, it was just a tiny general store.
And we couldn't even land a regular gig there.
Do you really think there's going to be a next time for us?
I mean...
It's been nearly a year.
They're cute though.
Oh.
Oh, it's been a year?
Boss used to be a director at Tetra and was even Pretty's
manager.
What?
Honestly, it's not as impressive as it sounds.
What do you mean, shoot?
He was like the manager of the best was it, the most famous
singing Niki.
Who can save this place overnight.
If I'm being honest, connections the future doesn't exactly
look bright so what oh my god i thought it would be like the
first month or two not a year watches preka i got scouted oh
it's not a huge place but it's definitely better than here
they've got around five regular shows running at the moment
oh oh no the band is Who knows exactly how to develop pop
stars?
They're spawning!
If I joined, I'd be coming in as a new member.
They even mentioned the center position.
I doubt they really mean it.
No, that's just...
Are you going to accept it?
He's giving her like a carrot on the stick.
I mean, there's really no reason not to.
I mean, it's a big opportunity.
No reason not to.
Oh, she's trying so hard.
look at her like she messed up her debut performance drank a
can of soda and immediately hold herself up in the practice
room remember when we first met her she knew nothing she was
terrible okay now all right now these years just look at her
nothing changed it's not just talent she works ridiculously
hard like hard and all the while she plays the leader I
don't think Anise would have wanted her to say if she find
out she had a better opportunity she would want her to
succeed missing a practice I literally thought she was gonna
say look she's still terrible but at least she's still
trying why does she put in so much effort it's crazy she
believes I don't even know what to say you're rooting for
her hmm yeah I want to see her shine hmm so preka why don't
you just go somewhere else honestly you've got the best
skills yeah why do you stay a bit all over the place why
does preka say came out vague a niece and I both died at
pretty's comeback concert so at least we're connected
somehow but you You were supposed to debut as a human.
Oh my god.
No.
Sorry.
Everything got canceled when I ended up dying in a traffic
accident Oh shit.
There's like a tiny little moth What really drew me in was
boss since he used to be a tetra director and his manager.
Oh no, I'm scared.
Oh, I fucking hate bugs Oh my god, I was confident in my
skills like moth things.
But well look where that got me
oh no i don't know if it flew away where did it fly to i
don't want it on me one's clueless as hell and the other
just coasts on our looks somehow i know i just don't fuck
with bugs i don't fuck with bugs oh my god i don't where did
it go the door is open seriously working hard she just keeps
improving what about me as always oh after spending all that
time together um okay give me a sec i guess i got attached
so yeah that's why i can't leave oh it is stockholm syndrome
right into the worst one huh i know right where did it go it
was flapping all over the place there's no way it's just how
did it get in my She's doing it wrong there's no windows
here going in how did it all we can do is give it our all
How did this bump get in here what there's no windows you're
trying to do a three-person routine on your own Of course
it's always come on let's do it together I'll walk you
through it okay Oh thanks I'm afraid of spiders in real life
I'm not afraid of virtual spiders expressions during
practice virtual spot like it's on the screen like it's like
how it's like when people are like how are you kidding like
just turn off the screen where'd everyone go
alright I was still listening it was just there was a moth
flying around and I am now super paranoid I am so paranoid
right now I just don't want it on me that's really it I want
when i was walking when i was on a trip i was walking i got
smacked by a giant ass moth on the face but it's like one of
those like the tiny one you know what i'm talking about the
really tiny ones that are like i don't know how they're like
the really tiny ones that's the one that's flying around my
room right now and i'm super paranoid because i don't fuck
with that.
What's it?
The minigame.
We're going to do the minigame.
I just don't want it touching me.
I don't... Oh, it's like I'm afraid of ants too.
By the shop.
The shop might have stuff.
Okay.
Anything for free in the shop?
Nothing for free?
Alright.
I'll do the minigame then.
It's a rhythm based sound may play when you enter you can
digest okay yeah anise looks at the poster on the wall the
loading word constant are visible phew anise begins pacing
in circles around the practice room ha anise would you mind
sitting down you're making me dizzy how are you guys not
nervous after seeing that.
This moth?
I know.
Wait, am I the only one freaking out right now?
Seriously?
Am I the one losing it here?
Why would I freak out?
It's just the poster.
Mint looks at the poster.
Their faces stare back at her.
It should be fine.
Rattle, rattle, rattle.
The water bottle and Mint's hand shakes violently.
Of course I'm not fine.
See, I told you that happened.
Seriously?
What's with you, too?
It's not like the poster is cursed or anything.
That's the show.
It's not like we're amateurs.
But we're not exactly professionals yet.
Exactly.
We've never performed on a stage this big before.
What have we messed it up?
Way to jinx it.
Why aren't you guys making such a fuss over this?
Prika looks up the poster.
The concert date catches her eye.
So we're seriously running out of time.
What do we do?
What scene this got you nervous too?
Yeah, but not as bad as you two.
This won't do.
I should at least take this down.
I'm going to stop the auto.
They're reading way too fast.
Mint feels the poster off the wall and lays its face down.
Yeah, not seeing this makes this a whole lot easier.
I swear to God this mouth touches me.
I swear to fucking...
You got some...
You got time to stay.
that you got time to trade.
All right, let's practice.
It's the only way we survive.
I'm like, you know, like I'm moving a lot right now because
like, I don't want it to touch me.
So if it sees me moving, it will stop.
It won't go near me because they're like, whoa, what is this
moving thing?
What is this moving thing right now?
I'll take it with a gifted sub to Larry.
Thank you.
I'll start the music.
So get in position.
um got it bugs are i hate bugs i just i do not fuck with
insects at all like any type of insect i'm scared of any
type of them even the really tiny ones i just oh it just
gives me the creepy crawlies right now precomment take their
place in formation the center of the room all right let's go
music start all right there we go
all right touch the stars it's rhythm game time Oh, ooh!
Would you like to proceed?
I don't need the tutorial.
Which one should we do, guys?
Oh, it's...
Once you fly us on, you won't press the ready button.
Uh, check this out here if you want to look through the help
section.
Alright.
I'm so paranoid that I'm gonna get touched.
That's all right.
We're going in live.
All right, which sign?
The TT star gives you a pull?
I like the sound of that.
Where is it?
Is it be my star?
Does that give me a pull?
Oh, a cellarite.
Wait, there's...
Wait, Amali?
Amali's in here.
I know that name.
I'm gonna do be my star.
And change the difficulty as well as check the rankings for
it.
Unlock X remote.
Once you're ready, press here.
I got this.
What button do I press?
Wait.
Okay, I got...
Okay, it's these two.
There we go.
I had to figure out which buttons does what.
See, I figured it out.
This is too slow.
I think my favorite part is when I go to, like, arcades in
Japan, business, men after work with their little, like the,
when they locked in with their gamer gloves and do the
rhythm games, they go pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, it's so,
so cool to watch.
It's like, I had a rough day at work, time to do my rhythm
games, to let out the stress.
It's pretty cute, yeah.
And then you see their like little, like the business
briefcase too.
All right, I need a real challenge.
This is too easy.
Oh,
the music video is cute, too.
He knows everything.
One, two, three.
I love this side.
What?
What was that?
supposed to be?
I thought that was all the buttons!
What?
Was that not all the buttons?
Oh, I had to press space.
Guys, maybe I should have did the tutorial.
Maybe I should have done the tutorial.
Alright, do I get a little prize?
Someone said I do can now play the next song.
Wait, do I don't get the prize?
Go to settings
Oh, oh Oh, left shift Oh my god, there's a left shift
There's a There's a There's a left and a right shift as well
I didn't even get to see that Wait, how do you get like
prizes Alright, let's do Let's see.
Let's see how fuck this is.
Oh, mission.
Oh.
Okay, baby heart's not for me.
Baby heart is not.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, let's go normal.
Maybe, maybe it's, we're just a normal, maybe normal would
be my alley.
Here we go.
I just realized what the star reminds me.
It reminds me of Magnetic.
Like the, her, her voice.
All right.
This is more my speed.
I'm not a, you can tell I'm not a rhythm gamer.
Kling.
I
feel like rhythm gaming though, it's a lot about like how
like reflex type what like memorizing the beat maps
especially like the harder levels
it's like muscle memory right?
Oh my
god Oh I am I am I am
Yay!
Yeah, it's like muscle memory predicting my keys.
B!
I mean, that's all right.
As the non-rhythm player, I think that's all right.
I feel so alive.
All right.
I got that.
Do we think we have enough?
Do we have...
Do you guys think we have enough?
Okay, perform Accelerate to Completion once.
All right, Accelerate.
We gotta grab as many...
We gotta grab as many passes for a niece, guys.
When you get a niece...
If I just press all the buttons.
Oh, bum bum.
This song we haven't heard yet.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Oh my god, there's a...
He finally introduced the new buttons.
Oh my god, there's way too many buttons now.
Ah!
Oh my god, what am I pressing?
Oh my, keep pressing enter instead.
I do not like the shift button.
I don't know, maybe that's just...
That's just me, but the shift is like...
It throws me off.
I think you should rebind the shift one.
Oh my god, I pressed shift.
BADAM BADAM BADAM BADAM Okay
BAM BAM Okay Now I'm getting used to it BAM Yeah BAM BAM BAM
Holy shit this song is live
BADAMNANANANANANANANAN Oh Yay Perfect Yeah, STFJKL?
Yeah, that feels better, if I think.
Can I do re-bind it?
Is it possible to re-bind it?
I do not.
I really don't like the...
Okay, let's see.
General, sort, controls.
There you go.
I do not like the shift.
I change it.
Reset 2?
Custom.
There you go.
S.
Uh.
There you go.
That's a lot better.
Alright, let's do...
We need to do...
Clickbait.
Oh, there you go.
This is about right.
Yeah, I don't think I can do hard.
I'll just settle.
I'm...
I'll settle as the normie as I am.
Boom.
Bum It feels very kpop for sure the songs like I said like
her their songs reminds me of the group that did magnetic
Or cat's eye too Before before they went like EDM
Yeah, yeah.
Oh,
that random space threw me off.
That one was good.
I like that one.
I like that song.
I like the mapping for it too.
More than the shifts.
The shifts?
Through it fucked me up.
Oh, yay!
When they started introducing the shifts, I did not fuck
with that.
Do you think I have enough?
We'll do one last.
We'll do an Amalisa.
Yeah, Salas for one more.
I don't even know if I have...
If, like, if I need more or not.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, oh, whoops.
Oh, perfect.
Yeah, I'm locked in now.
I feel like rhythm game must be really hard to stream
because, like, what do I even say?
I have to, like, lock in.
I guess if you're really good at, like, rhythm game, you
can, it's, like, second nature.
But, like, I feel like I'm using both sides of my brain
right now this game.
And this is on normal.
I didn't think they would have the shifts.
Because it must be, like, super hard to commentate, too.
So you just mash like, how do you have, like, a
conversation?
If you're, like, one of the you play, like, the harder
difficulties.
They don't talk, they just like lock in the...
Yay!
Oh, S!
Okay, that one was the easier one.
All right.
Same.
I should have enough now.
All right, cancel.
That was fun, though.
That was fun.
That was cool that they made their own rhythm game.
to tie in with the new story, the new event, the idol event.
Let's see.
Alright, let's see if do we have enough?
Oh my god.
Are you...
Oh, I do have enough.
I have enough coins.
That's fine.
I have enough gems.
It's alright.
I have enough gems to make it.
Come on.
It's gonna go yellow, right?
Guys, it's gonna go yellow.
Guys, don't worry.
It's going to start glowing yellow right here, guys.
I worked so hard.
I worked so hard for the two.
It's okay.
Maybe I can get it one by one.
Imagine.
Imagine if I get this right here in one...
Oh my, of course it's a purple.
Guys, imagine if I get it, like, right here.
Guys, imagine.
Right here.
Okay, the next one.
No, single pose are not worth it, Doki.
But, like, imagine, though, what if.
it just happens but what exactly what if it's the next one
guys what if right here are you looking for something okay
wait maybe it maybe okay i can make it for you it's free i
don't know what that was but it was free i'll take it right
imagine though imagine right here Oh my god, you're gonna be
you're gonna be so silly when when like right here It's
gonna turn gold guys.
It's It's gonna you're gonna be you look so silly when
imagine like right here just think about it Look at that
Wait, I just need 10 more surely there's I should need $10
just imagine guys Surely there's a $10 here somewhere,
right?
Guys, if I get another $10, I can do one more pull.
I claimed everything.
I don't even know what I'm missing.
Guys, it can happen.
Just think about it.
Okay, wait, maybe I can find a free gem somewhere.
my god there it is oh my god yes there it is okay daily oh
my god see I told you I needed that 10 too and look at that
look at that there we go guys always believe all right let's
see back right here look at that got another free pull one
last pull but i have one i have enough i just need 50 more
you're gonna be so silly when this turns gold right here and
yes oh my god it's gonna turn gold down it's gonna it's
gonna turn you might it might look like it's blue but then
it's gonna it's yellow it's gonna be yellow right here
yeah guys i just need 50 i can let me search the couch for
some pennies guys i just need 50 cents let me let me search
the let me search the couch for the pennies surely there
must be something here the mission passes there must be a
free thing here okay 10 claim okay five points i must have
something else i can claim there must be something else did
you use all the codes what other what else am i missing
claim all obtain 50 points that has to be 50 points right
okay not here okay weekly okay 20 points okay there's a main
i still have the Connecting the server?
Alright, it's fine.
This finder has to be.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Claim all.
Wait, wait.
There we go.
That's... Guys, look at that.
Look at that.
Alright.
Here we go.
That's three more pulls.
That's three more.
It's alright.
It's okay.
I still have two more.
I still have two more, guys.
This is the last one.
Oh, this is it.
This is it.
This is where it leads up to.
It is all where it leads to.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, and it's going to turn gold.
Guys, it's going to turn gold right here.
Right?
It's going to turn yellow.
Oh.
Maybe if I wish for a niece, I don't even want...
Oh wait, I should actually wish for that.
I should actually wish for that in honor.
Maybe if I...
Maybe if I just...
Maybe I just wish...
I wish for stuff.
Maybe...
And then...
Maybe I'll get something beautiful.
Please.
Maybe...
Maybe something beautiful will show up.
Something beautiful.
Yay!
Guys!
Guys, I got her knees!
We did it!
See, I told you it worked.
Guys, I told you.
Look at that.
Downers, BTFO, right there.
Look at that, we did it, guys.
We pulled at these, everyone.
Look at that, I told you.
I sure showed you.
I, where's at these?
You know what, at these?
This is as good as it's gonna get.
All right, Anise, you're going.
All right, Anise, you're gonna get it all.
You're gonna...
You're gonna get it all.
There we go.
Might as well.
She deserves it.
She deserves it All eyes on her
Any missions that are Cakewalk Look at that Now she has
everything Yay You're so strong now Where is she Look at
that She's even stronger than mine Than my little mermaid
You're so strong now, Nis.
I put it all on you.
Alright.
Give her a doll.
How do I give her a doll?
Just nothing.
Any mission do not worry, Commander.
We will protect you.
You're so strong now.
Oh, is it this?
Oh.
Might as well.
Yeah, fuck it.
I keep it.
Maintain.
For an attribute.
So you can buy a collection item.
Subtain.
Exchange the maintenance materials.
A fully favorite.
Oh, okay.
Oh, cool.
That's new.
Oh, I gotta feed you?
No, you're gonna starve.
The selective method of decimation of AXP and the
probability of achieving success.
Super success in maintenance elevates the collection items
to the maximum development the stage achievable in this
current phase All right, well, there's no point in reading
this because I'm not gonna feed you
It's a doll
It's a doll it doesn't need feeding Where is Let's get a
niece in here.
How do I swap to one?
Anise.
Anise, where are you, Anise?
Anise, I know you're here.
Anise, where are you?
Hey, guys.
I'm still going to keep streaming.
I'm just going to swap games.
But, I'll say again, huge shout-out to Nike.
Oh, it's the top four squares.
Okay.
Where was it?
Was it Lobby?
Oh, it's Lobby, right?
Alright, there we go.
Oh, yeah, I put in two Maharas.
Okay.
Where's Anise?
There you go.
Guys, look at that.
I got Anise, guys.
It's just all Anise.
And then Little Mermaid.
And then Anise.
And then...
Whoops, all Anises.
I need missions that are a cakewalk.
But...
You can get...
Remember to use the link pinned in my chat.
To get 160 pulls.
And for SSR Nikes.
free guys you shout out to nikki nikki again for sponsoring
today's stream and inviting me to be part of the concert it
was really a cool experience like i said i didn't expect to
be invited uh for this um it looked really really cool and i
really appreciate it so thank you again to nikki for
sponsoring today's stream to help let me celebrate uh 3.5 uh
anniversary and anisa's special day really want to watch
that it's just so cool guys i i just want to watch it again
i won't watch my performance again it's actually so cool all
right let's do it god why can't it be as cool as that dokey
all right it was a it was it turned out really really good
and like the final product like i I said, I went in so
blind, I didn't know how it was gonna turn out.
So I love how it turned out in the end, yeah.
Enough yapping, it's Doki Bird Time.
Oh,
there we go.
I can't be as cool as past Doki.
Fun.
You know, I'll hide myself too so you get the full
experience.
Where did Doki Bird go?
Oh, there she is.
Yeah, move Christ the Doki.
She's the coolest Doki and the Doki Birds.
Gosh, she's so cool.
me.
She's me, guys.
Put that Doki on screen.
Oh my God.
That's right.
When you say she's cool, you're saying I'm cool.
Just remember that.
You wish you were.
I am her.
What are you talking about?
She is me.
She is cool you're okay why can't we have this dokey in the
dokeyverse oh cool thank you for the rain thank you thank
you we literally just finished watching um the sponsor uh
the sponsor video me performing that in the nikki concert
we're actually it's just about the swap games all right
let's see let me fix change the title real quick uh again
thank you again to Uh, guess we gotta watch it.
You're right.
Let's watch it.
Guess that means we get to watch it again, guys.
Encore, Encore, Encore.
Whoa!
Let's go.
We get to see her again.
How many encores does that make?
Not enough.
In this land of endless night We call us fun Oh my god, a
fourth encore We cut her in
line We pierced her line
Break the dark
God, she's so cool She's so cool And that automatically
makes me cool Because she's actually me Dude
You can't say she was cool when she's literally me.
You can't say that.
You have to group us two together because we're both dokees.
You're not the same.
She has my face.
Thank you again for the red.
swapping games right now what what could it be what could
actually was tempted to swap to Overwatch just because I was
there's the there's apparently drops for the Wynton badge
but that really don't want to play Overwatch right now I
really I don't feel like play Overwatch right now so there's
a new Wynton badge for uh for drops I'm like, I don't Do I
really Maybe how many hours Is it for the Winston badge
Guys?
How many hours
Alright We swap games Did you guys enjoy Did you guys enjoy
that concert?
Well Speaking of concerts I will be performing In my own 3D
concert On July 4th And in LA with Chibi Doki and a lot of
surprise guests.
I'll be announced later on the next two weeks.
And you go check out your tickets right now.
Is Past Doki?
Yes, if I say Past Doki is going to be a guest, would you
buy a ticket?
Would you buy a ticket?
Yes, Past Doki will be one of the guests.
at my own concert yes please feel free to do exclamation
point concert and check out grab your ticket today it'll be
the one at July 4th there's three different concerts going
on on July 2nd, 3rd and 4th mine will be on July 4th alright
we're playing rivals now maybe okay how does anyone know how
many hours we need a how many hours uh you have to play for
uh to get the winton badge because maybe i'll segue to
overwatch instead or doom queuing now all right thank you
for the 400 biddies thank you thank you the badge is one sub
oh shit all right oh my gosh wait my sorry i'm frozen
because v2 studio fucking broke down all right all right if
it's just i'll play an hour of Overwatch.
How about that?
All right.
Is there drops going on in Overwatch or do I count in the...
I don't even know if the drops do have to be part of the
system or not?
I need a...
YouTube Studio crashed.
Give me a sec.
Oh, Steam crashed.
Never mind.
Yeah, that makes sense, actually.
Do... There are drops?
Okay.
I was just wondering.
All right.
I forgot.
I like Winston.
There you go.
I don't play Winston.
We'll do one hour of Overwatch.
I haven't played in a long ass time.
So we'll see how it goes.
Alright.
I have to reboot my shit.
Because my.
Oh my god.
It actually shuts shit down.
me a sec at the force quit this where's the other vtube
studio where's the one that fucking died on me is it this
one no i closed the wrong one all right i gotta open this
again
let's see what is my
uh oops Ooh, my immersion.
Oops.
My immersion.
No!
Now, my immersion.
Who are you?
All right, let's see.
You make sure I got everything sorted out for this.
because i don't remember my sound settings uh battle net
okay sign out sign in
okay all right what is my overwatch settings sound settings
7.3
It's been a while.
I just want the Winton badge.
Winton.
So you just have to gift the sub to get it.
Can I gift myself?
Wait, can I?
All right, one lucky person is going to...
So I can have a Winton badge.
One lucky person is going to get a sub on my channel.
Okay.
All right, gifty sub.
Okay, one sub, please.
Pay.
Who gets it?
Who's the lucky one?
Who gets...
Oh, yeah!
I got my win done!
Yippee!
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, yeah, the new hero.
I forgot about that.
Wait, who got it?
We got congratulations out of the four.
Thank you for the 10 gifted songs.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
You can now talk.
By the way, they added a new thing.
Where doctor, they gave a tier one song.
Thank you.
Look at that.
Where's my winch done?
Ha ha ha.
Look at this.
Guys, look.
Wait, it didn't show up.
Excuse me, where is my Wint- Oh, there, let me hide a badge.
Okay, how do I show it?
There we go, Wintun.
Look at that.
Now I have my Wintun badge.
Now it's worth it.
Golden, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you, thank you.
They added a lot of new stuff for the new season.
And one of them was that now you can talk to people at the
end of the game.
People only did it for the first couple of days And now no
one talks to each other again It was just like a one-time
thing Look at that
Everyone's like I got it on my system I got it on my system
Now I don't wish to interact with anyone anymore So dude if
you guys want your Winston badges Today is the day
Today is the day I usually don't care about the badges
Except for the fact This one is Winston.
Yay.
Oh, 10-year anniversary.
I just realized the sound was not on for all of that.
You were just watching a muted cutscene.
Annie, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I just realized that.
I was like, damn, this sounds sick.
And you're like, sound.
it sounds sick what do you mean hidden thank you for gifting
a tier one sub thank you thank you golden thank you for
giving a tier one sub to cheese many thank you a gift a tier
one sub to me alan thank you for gifting a tier one sub
thank you thank you winton i do it for winton all right when
does open qn how am i still in g am.
Oh, in two days.
I was like, when?
Oh, shit.
Still masters?
Is it not?
Alright, let's go.
Oh, I'm still a GM?
Let's go.
Let's take a go.
I did not expect me to still have it.
Alright.
I mean, I'll take it.
I'll take speed still grandmaster let's go gordon thank you
for a tier one gifting a sub thank you thank you gabbert
thank you for gifting a tier one sub to kr thank you thank
you really appreciate it guys snake thank you for giving a
tier one sub to cali thank you thank you i'm all here for
one done all right let's see death match pamela's a new aim
does anyone remember the aim training daddy thank you for
the tier Gotta give thing five, two, one-sos.
Thank you.
Someone needs to fill this saddle.
Where people at?
Aw.
Alright, people.
Until I haven't fucking played video games in a while.
I'm gonna blame it.
I haven't...
Oh, fuck.
This is a...
I need to put my actual pad on top of the glass pad.
I do not like, there you go.
Feels more smooth now.
All right, I am very rusty.
I've not aimed in a long time.
I do not have time to aim right now.
I've been stuck in work hell.
I'm like that business, I'm like those businessmen in Japan.
Oh, get ready for me to die!
We're like, I clock out after work and I head to the
arcades.
I'm like the salary man right now.
I've been working non-stop with the concert shit and
everything.
There's just no time.
The fact that this doesn't stun anymore makes me so sad.
I...
I miss...
I missed the stun, stun Cree, stun Cassidy.
God, this doesn't work as well.
Stun Cassidy.
It's been so long.
But thank you for the tier.
Gifting a tier one sub.
Thank you.
It doesn't.
Kill still.
Let's go.
Whoa.
Still have Fad the Hammer.
That's fine.
Okay.
Armor, thank you for giving me a tier one, so Dasachi, thank
you.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh my god, where's my game?
I'm only GM5.
Only.
I'm so, I see it as a low elo only because, um, because it's
not, it's, I don't know.
Because it's not champ.
I don't even know where the hero is.
heels are suffering from success there we go oh it's just me
oh shit he went Cassidy he's like I'm better than this he
might be no never mind he never mind he It might not be.
Duck, thank you for...
Thank you for giving me a tier 1 sub to me.
Thank you, thank you.
Arbor King, thank you for gifting a tier 1 sub.
The lemon, thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Okay, I'll...
Whoa, I won't give you the satisfaction.
You really want to kill me.
Oh my god, he really wanted me dead.
I didn't want to give him the status, but I guess nothing I
could do.
Oh, that guy did every shot.
Alright.
I don't know what to vote for.
I hate all.
I'll let fate.
I'll let random map decide.
All of them.
They're not the greatest, I will say.
They're all pretty mediocre.
Give me King's Row or Death.
Oh my god.
We ran them into a worse map.
We ran them into a disgusting escort map.
I hate, I hate this escort so much.
What's broken now?
Diva, right?
Diva.
I'll just run in Diva.
I heard Vendetta's broken, though.
But whatever.
Diva's the only one I go.
No, Diva's been broken for multiple seasons.
She is, like, hard.
She's a hard-broken character right now.
Van Winton.
I don't want to get yelled at.
I...
Oh my god, rat trap.
Fuck, okay.
I think it was like Kiri and...
Wait, Hanron's bet?
No, I'm sorry.
Larly's bet.
God damn it.
I really don't want to play Kiriko.
Of course I get the junk rat one trick.
Fucking course.
Quail, thank you for gifting a tier one.
up to he he went on neppers thank you for gifting a tier one
sub to nomen they can thank you gordon thank you for gifting
a tier one sub to germa nice look at all the winton on the
in the chat now went done i just do one match and then i
swap i heard her kills are better but our tvp is slower what
did they never nerf her.
I didn't nerf her.
I just heard her TP is worse now, but her heels are better.
Oh, 35 meters to 30.
Oh, it's her range.
It's her range.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's so far.
It's so...
Okay, I see now.
I'm not used to it.
I was like, I could TP now.
It's so it's not as oh.
It's actually not, I'm not used to it.
I was like, I could TP this, and I could not I could not TP
this.
I'm not used to it.
I'm not used to the really short TP range.
You can tell I have a been playing in a while, though.
Alright.
Yeah, we're not winning this.
We might be fucked.
I didn't think I'd go...
I thought I would have placement matches, but I guess not...
I legitimately thought I would be doing placement matches,
not straight into GM, because I have not played in so long.
Alright.
It does not help that we do have a Junker at One Trick.
It really does Oh, please.
I've not stopped healing.
I don't want a heal bot.
But apparently, I might have to.
Oh, I'm for Mizuki.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I'm trying to help out as much as I can.
okay all right that's very unlucky all right here we go oh I
got my oh this is not I don't guys I have a feeling that our
team is a just a maybe just a Maybe.
It also might be because of me as well, because I haven't...
I did not expect myself.
Okay.
No, I don't want to peek that, actually.
Oh my god!
My TP!
I think the last time I played was a week before the season
ended.
He's gonna live... Oh!
He unfortunately was not going to live that.
Unfortunately.
I do want a DPS, though.
Alright, maybe I can.
Whoa!
Oh, goodbye!
Goodbye!
Hello.
She's so low.
It's fine.
We have the auto aim bot.
It's okay.
Me and the junk rats got this.
It's alright.
She ricocheted him away from my shots.
Oh.
Everything is fine.
Get me out of here.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Never mind.
I can't even look away for like a second.
Oh, I have a...
out here though might be oh my god you fucking getting me
it's okay i believe in my i don't believe in my juno i i
don't believe in my junior i don't have my speed my speed
thing no it's on me though oh now i do why was it is this i
just haven't played in a while And I went straight into it.
I literally thought I would have...
I would have...
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
I would have placement matches.
And I'm fucking rough right into it.
Why don't we have an Emory?
I thought he was good.
Goodbye.
I would love to help you.
but you're gonna have to survive on your own.
Are you kidding me?
The one second?
Gordon, thank you for gifting two tier one souls.
To BNC, thank you.
All right.
It's okay.
I can get back into the groove of things.
Just need a little bit.
I need a little bit of time.
It might be rough right now.
I just need like one or two games.
Oh my god.
And he's like...
He's like so low.
I couldn't get out of there.
What's that?
Just a...
Exactly.
Just repositioning.
Okay.
Linus, thank you for giving me a tier 1 sub, thank you,
thank you.
Mike, thank you for giving me a tier 1 sub, thank you, thank
you.
Look at all the winters in the chat.
Well, I hope our Ana's healing.
Oh.
Unfortunately, unlucky for them, I do not have...
Unlucky.
I do not have a thing.
uh jev thank you for twitch prime thank you thank you marco
thank you for a tier one sub thank you thank you give me a
tier one sub thank you thank you oh my god i'm like i can't
pee oh we got him all right we have life weaver now i want a
dps But there's so much damage!
Okay, maybe I can now with a life weaver.
I could take an off angle.
Should be able to.
We should be able to kill him, though, can we?
No, we cannot.
Jesus Christ.
It's so rough for us.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
That's the risk I'm willing to take!
come on life weaver you can do this okay life weaver i did
you did you could have came over to me
okay play it fuck i have to i cannot peek right now i'm
literally one so
so I hate the new TP range.
It's so fucking weird.
I think it's like if you're so used to When you're so used
to old Kiriko it fucks with me so much with the The old TP
range the new TP range
All right, that's good
All right
He's fine.
He's so healthy He is so healthy.
Oh my god, I'm too scared to fucking push up by myself.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
I did so much to save your life, so I hope you...
She doesn't live.
Please give me that TP.
Please give me...
I gave you all the resources I could.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, I did not see the Emory behind us.
What?
Gio, thank you for the tier.
Give the tier one so thank you.
All that for him to die.
I gave him...
I gave him all the resources I could.
It is...
Oh, and then he swaps to Emory.
Like, that was gonna help us now.
I'm like As if that's gonna help us Over time I mean our
junk rat wasn't that I'm gonna avoid the junk rat Never mind
I should not justify it I was like he wasn't that bad But I
shouldn't justify it Alright Poor shit oh my gosh it's so
weird trying to where's my percentage here alright I can
like lose two more games
I can lose two more games here
let's see
oh no I just wanted the Wintum badge
alright Midtown Hollywood I I don't like Hollywood.
I just don't like the high ground.
Circuit Royale is fun.
I just want the Wink the Edge.
That's the only reason.
Might play, like, two more games.
Two more games of Overwatch, and then we'll swap to Rivals.
I like Circuit Royale.
I think Circuit Royale is fun.
I just don't...
I don't...
I don't like Hollywood.
The Hollywood high ground control is, like, a lot.
I just know what a bad diva.
And what else gonna ban?
I'm just gonna select my usual ban line.
Sigma.
Does Vendetta still good?
Because I don't know.
I know Vendetta is really good and high, Eelow.
Vendetta Zarya is like crazy broken.
I don't know, Miss.
They give her gifting a sub.
Thank you.
Oh, hey.
All right, I'll do a lie.
Oh, is she low 40s?
Because I knew she was good last season.
I just don't know if she's good now.
Because my bandline last season was...
It was...
Diva, Vendetta...
Fuck, what was the third one?
Diva, Vendetta, and then the third one was, like, free space
with whatever the map was.
Maybe Zarya?
If, like, we didn't ban Vendetta about Kozaria.
I haven't played a lot in a while, so...
Let's try.
This is my first game of the current season.
I have not played the current season at all.
It's my first game of it.
Aras, thank you for gifting us up!
Thank you!
So, like...
So, I haven't played oh why is my rissa here oh my
god he's she's so low though all right i need to be over
here i hope our honor is healing him because all right Oh my
god, she's so low A fucking course
Alright I'm gonna take an angle here Oh my god, healer Arisa
though Oh my god, my thing is so dead
My thing is so dead here She's so one She's so low Come on.
Put it here.
Come on, I really want to shoot him so badly.
Yay!
Free payload!
I guess I'll push it.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
I gotta heal.
Hello.
Alright.
Everybody's fine.
It's fine.
Really rusty though on Illari.
Oh my god, I cannot see.
I can't see shit!
Oh my god, go Bob!
Go!
Go where I'll heal Bob!
Okay, it doesn't matter.
Oh my god, she's so healthy.
I do not have any heals, so I hope you live.
There we go.
Am I getting healed right now?
No!
She was so low!
I need to stop jumping.
as much.
I'm so used to jumping a lot from rivals.
It's okay, the pylon is still there.
Oh, the pylon.
I put the pylon here so it doesn't die.
He's so dead.
There you go.
You'll live.
I don't know about me, though.
No!
Anna, looked at you!
I gave you a pylon!
And how could you?
I'm at the swap.
Killing my pylon too fast.
Oh, this is bad.
There was nothing we could do.
They literally...
Oh man.
The sacrifice.
I might swap, honestly.
I think I'm going to swap.
I might need more heals.
Don't worry.
The pylons got you.
Oh my god.
I got you.
There we go.
Ignite.
Don't worry, Arissa.
Take this pylon.
Oh.
I do not feel I do personally do not feel safe here though
look at that we're taking space Arissa you and me
oh my god
oh oh Arissa I don't know if this was a good idea Arissa oh
no shit Arissa why did you take the TP
Oh my god, Arisa
Oh, holy I don't know why Arisa went up there I was like,
Arisa, get down You're so low She like went It wouldn't mind
if she took the TP At like 100 HP She took the TP at like 70
So I was Oh, that's not good.
See near the pylon!
And I could try and kill her.
Okay, do we...
We don't have...
I'm gonna take...
Get rid of my pylon real quick.
Okay, the moment...
Oh my...
I mean, okay.
That's good.
oh my god wait where is he there go it's fine it's worth it
it's not worth it i didn't think you was gonna fucking nano
i'm so bad with nano when someone nano means i go like i
like panic so hard i panic so hard with nano oh a fucking
course my now my pylon does i'm just not a fan of It's just
me though, it's just a me thing.
I'm just really bad with Nano.
I'm trying to keep you alive right now.
There you go.
Ooh.
Me and you.
You have to kill him!
I shot him in the head!
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Okay, okay.
There we go.
It's worth it.
Alright, nice.
We got this.
Let's go!
I feel like I'm like a headless chicken right now.
I'm walking around.
It's okay.
It's working, though.
It's working.
I might feel like a headless chicken.
chicken because i feel like i'm so confused 80 of the time
but it's working it's working i took an off angle right
father thank you for the tier one so thank you thank you now
i'm saying we're giving a tier one sub the last thank you
thank you as long as it's working that's all that works for
me
as long as it's working
I carry my burden.
Hello.
I hear you.
I feel like she played Zenyata.
Zenyata is good on this map.
But I'm already here.
Fuck that.
I mean, I might swap the Zen after this.
The reality was...
not as inspiring.
You gave Evie courage when she needed it most, Captain.
Alright.
Yeah, Zen feels... it's apparently really good for this map
too.
Alright.
Put it here.
Put that here actually.
Oh yeah, see he's going Zen, he knows.
Oh shit.
My god.
Oh, that is not a good...
There we go.
Put the pile on here.
Holy shit.
Alright, I have to put this here, actually.
This is bad.
I actually might have to swap this in.
That's fucked.
How did he go?
That's so fucked.
He's so dead.
Oh my god, let's hope.
This is bad for our Arisa because yeah I have to go Zen.
This is so bad for Arisa.
I can't even do anything about it.
I can't even.
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh my god.
Let's hope.
Okay.
I'm trying
What the fuck was that?
What was that dog though?
Oh my I have to swap.
What was that, Nano?
Alright.
It's fine.
I wanted to swap off anyways.
I had to.
to oh oh wait wait there's an honor behind us what the fuck
our team did it
oh my god our team our team all right i'm gonna give this to
her i'm gonna use this to him he deserves it you could get
It's a good-ass treat after that.
I mean, I guess I can.
He deserves that.
Or good for a job well done.
Alright.
I don't know what to upgrade, what to get, though, for...
Oh my god, keep using E instead.
Oh, Anna.
oh me oh my god our honor was so mispositioned not the
floating perk oh yeah i forgot that's one of the perk or i
don't know why our honor did not position herself after life
steal okay i haven't played zen i didn't i'm not played i
keep pressing e instead of for some reason i see like Oh,
I'm very mispositioned.
I might...
No, I'm fine.
That's good.
I'm okay.
All right.
Oops.
Oh, Rissa!
Rissa!
Oh, he's still up.
I might actually...
Yeah.
So...
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Not nice anymore?
Alright, not the floating one.
I didn't put the floating.
It sucks our...
Our fucking Orissa is getting...
This is bad.
This is bad for us.
This is so bad.
We need an Emory.
We need a fucking Emory.
He just does the fucking Emory.
Yeah, Kierko's bad.
Our Risa is very aggressive.
And it's not very good for us.
Because at the I have to balance our orb out with the Arisa
and the DPS.
Oh my gosh, she keeps pushing us away.
Whoop.
I think our Ana needs to alter our soldier for it.
All right.
Oh.
Oh Oh Oh, he's oh I saw him too late.
I don't even know what perk I got.
What is that?
Oh second second harmony.
Okay We did it I have all here I'm I don't even know.
I hope I use it correctly Not high I should get on high
ground Ooh, that's not good.
I don't want to peek that.
Hey, guys.
All right.
None of us dropped down.
Hello, me and the Zen said hi.
Why was I dropped?
Why did I have to drop down?
Why did the...
What else?
Drop down with...
Man, it would be nice.
Maybe I shouldn't use that.
Maybe I shouldn't have used my Zen ult there, but like don't
want drop down.
No, no, I drop down.
I got scared.
I was like, are we really gonna get C9?
Is that really gonna happen?
And of course I ulted.
I was the only one that touched it.
Like, I was like, are we really gonna get C9 right now?
I waited, too.
I waited till it hit two meters.
It was at two meters.
And then I went on it.
And then I even, I didn't shoot for, I didn't shoot.
Until I was like, I got shot at once.
And I was like, I gotta pop the up.
Second part, I tried just in his story.
One extra.
We want... I don't do dual harmony.
I guess I should have let them see nine.
I should have let the chance of see nine.
Alright, here we go.
Arissa is very aggressive.
Arissa is very aggressive, so she...
It's so hard to keep her alive.
It doesn't help because we're running...
They're running...
They're running Zen.
Like...
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
I didn't...
That was my bad.
I shouldn't have peeked at.
It's fine.
They got rid of the tank.
I didn't realize she had an LOS of me.
Because I really wanted to kill the... I think it was
worth... It was... The exchange was worth it.
It was worth it.
We got to kill the tank for it.
It's fine.
I will say... I am super rusty, though.
And it's my bad.
I'm so scared of peeking right now.
Nice.
I'm not gonna pick too much.
Holy shit!
So aggressive!
Alright, nice.
Do it, yeah.
So aggressive, she- the one- yeah, so aggressive, but then
she also didn't touch point.
I will say that.
She was as aggressive as she wanted it to be.
I don't think I should play Lari because they're on Zenyada.
I don't think.
I think I should play Zen.
If we lose, I will say I am definitely a weak link on the
scene.
When did they change the placement stuff I feel like
placements is nice I like placements I was so surprised I
was I still kept my rank I did not expect that I was like I
surely I won't grief people after not touching the game for
a while I always like placements I personally love I like
placements because it's like it helps especially you haven't
touched it.
The game.
We haven't touched the game in a while.
It helps a lot.
Oh.
He's very confident.
What the?
My god.
That's a lot of damage.
Alright.
I did not expect him to die so fast.
I hope I can...
I need to put this on him.
Oh my god.
I cannot peek that, though.
Oh.
I really don't want to peek.
Whoa!
Oh my god, he's so low.
get over Yana get over here oh my god oh my god it's just me
and you oh my god we did it we did it oh my god oh it's the
end game the end game is all that matters
We did it, Rissa.
Who would have thought?
You and I.
Not me.
I got skills that matter.
Who would have thought?
That was...
Oh my god, my heart was beating there.
My heart was, like, beating.
I'm giving my soul.
I'm not even in.
You know what?
Anna, you deserve it.
I can't deserve that.
Not me.
not me oh that yeah that no uphill 100 30 hell yeah let's go
let's go at the kills that mattered fuck yeah who is that
not me not me
god that was intense that was intense one what was it all
right does anyone remember it was called something, right?
Settings, import goat, jeans.
Is that the one?
Guys, what was the aim?
What was the aim training?
Custom lobby?
Was it jeans?
Ah, there it is.
For those who, yeah, for those who want to get practice,
it's like their own aim trainer.
Traveling to Havana.
Normal, rapid.
what is that there has to be where's the other one how do i
get out of here this doesn't seem like where was it there
was one for tracking
is that it there was another version of this i saw But this
is like apparently an aim labs for Overwatch.
Obviously it'd be better if I can...
It's not as good for me right now because I'm like aiming so
slow.
Like actual gamers would be like...
I'm just like...
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop,
boop.
boop i don't get out of here get me out of here oh 30 more
seconds all right boop boop boop boop boop boop i can
there's a pattern
it's a little bit of a pattern right here
being a little faster at least
I never do aim training, though.
Aim God, let's go!
Oh my god, there's more?
There's more?
It's the same thing.
Alright, let's see.
What?
Leave game?
I remember there was more to it.
It's not just...
It was not just that.
It was the one where you can...
You can...
practice tracking like actual aim labs and jeans.
Let's start.
I saw it.
Custom wrap.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't turn around.
Silly me.
I never turn around.
All right.
There you go.
Tracking.
Yeah, this one.
This is aim trainer.
This one.
This is...
I fucking hate this
I'm so jittery here holy shit get me out of here this is why
I don't aim train I just go in and play it seems miserable
I'm sorry it seems like a fucking miserable experience I
just play the game
we're both That, well, that's so sad.
Maybe I do need it.
Whoa.
Ooh.
Oh.
I would like to walk away from the Doomfist.
The Mercy Parkour.
Isn't the it ain't Nerf Mercy Movement?
And then there's a fucking Mercy Strike going on right now
where all Mercy players are playing tank.
And they're like, if you don't want us to terrorize your
lobby, Contact Blizzard right tweet at Blizzard right now
and then Blizzard untagged themselves from the tweet I
thought that was fucking hilarious.
Did that mean they read the tweet and then they untagged
themselves like They at the Blizzard Twitter and they're
like we don't want it to have anything to do with it But
that's fucking wild to me That's right I don't respect your
1v1 That's bad.
Oh my god, they didn't respect it.
Are those strikes real?
Yes.
I do not doubt what Mercy players say.
I don't doubt it.
If it was any other character but Mercy, I feel like they're
just fucking around.
But the fact that it was a Mercy player that said it, I
believe it.
and I like how people were like thank God they're playing
tank we need more tank players they're like good they're
playing something useful all right never doubt a mercy
player they spend their entire I think like if you look at a
mercy players if you look at mercy players like skin
collection it will not be their collection has gone to at
least $1,000 alone.
Like, the amount of cosmetics they own on Mercy alone, I
think it's worth at least a thousand.
At least.
That's like the low end.
No, you don't understand.
That is the low end of a Mercy collection.
Mythics are alone.
Isn't a Mythic skin?
Like, how much is a Mythic skin?
It's like, like, 50-plus dollars?
Guys?
And they have two.
It's, like, 50-plus dollars for a Mythic skin.
80!
It's 80 dollars.
So, if they own...
A lot of the mercies, they own two of the Mythic skins.
So, that's almost $200.
Oh, ha-ha-ha-ha.
Couldn't kill me.
For a Mythic skin.
Like, the...
The big skin.
the the mucho skin
select your hero the collectible skin
who spends $80 on a skin do not say that in front of a mercy
player or a Kiriko player honestly I don't know why we're
not grouping Kiriko they're the same type they're the same
type of player
we must not forget get the Kiriko players, too.
Oh, do we ban?
Alright.
Emory.
Oh, yeah.
We should ban Emory.
I forgot.
Fucking OP Emory is down.
Woo-y-ing.
I feel like I have to play Kiriko with Woo-ing, right?
I might as well.
Ooh, Grandmaster, too.
Ooh, we have a pride player.
We're probably saved up from their battle pass.
Probably.
There are mercy players that...
That do not.
Mr. Goonbox.
The Goonbox, the junk rat player.
Okay, let's see if I can...
Actually, DPS.
Why no Winston?
I'm not a Winston player.
I'm just here to...
I'm just here to get the badge.
Oh my god, how are you guys?
I looked away for one second.
Oh no.
Our poor Ryan.
Our poor Ryan was not poor fucking.
Why?
Oh yeah, he got pooped up.
There was nothing I could do.
I could, I should have just let him die.
Ah, fuck.
I heard Maga is meta now.
He's just so OP.
No Winton.
Hello, Flats!
And sadly, no Winton.
I saw Winton badge.
That's the only reason why I'm back.
Why is there a hog here?
Do you think if I TP the hog, I'd die?
Time to find out!
You're shamed!
Oh, you didn't kill her?
That's fine.
She has self-heal.
Jesus Christ.
Nope.
Barry!
Oh my god, that Mercy was so confident!
So confident that Riz.
Right there.
Trying to see if they show up.
Oh, oh, there's a ferret.
Oh, whoop, can't you?
If not aim is not that good.
Well, I'll just, I'll be here.
All right, soldier, me and you.
Me and you.
Oh, me feed.
Oh, that mercy.
Thank God they have a mercy.
a mercy player thank god where is she there yeah i'm glad
wait val actual val or streamer is that streamer name val
the mercy val i don't know if that's a streamer mode name i
need streamer mode
oh i don't think he realized he was was gonna get ready he's
gonna oh just made it oh fuck that's unlucky sorry they used
everything though oh fuck they got 50% I want stream remote
just cuz like if I'm if I'm not throwing not intentionally I
But you know what I mean, if I'm losing and I'm not doing so
well, I don't want them to know it's me.
Oh.
You know, you know those moments when you don't want to be,
you want to be public?
It'd be like, whoops.
Oh my god.
I should never TP.
I had streamer mode.
And then they raised the requirements for streamer mode.
They were like...
It used to be like 500 games.
And then they...
No, because then people be like...
You know how people get?
They're like, ha ha ha.
At Doki Bird.
In Overwatch people, they are...
They hurt you into the soul.
Do I have it now?
I don't know.
It was 750 games, and I do not have 750 games, and it
frustrates me.
I hate it.
All right.
Display players, privacy.
Oh my god, do I have...
Nope.
Yeah.
Yeah, I had it when it was 500.
It was 500 wins, and they've increased...
increased it to 750.
So I don't have it anymore.
I used to have streamer mode.
It's very frustrating.
No, there is.
Still fucks with me though, like the whole...
Where is my... I don't even know which button is my... I
need healing.
I don't know what I like to see.
she's alive not him though not him there you go i'm trying
so hard to keep him up
okay whoa how did he get her what the out of you get the
pharaoh that's crazy that's a crazy oh my god
He is so fucked right now.
No, I'm so fucked, too.
Why did it increase it?
Hackers.
Because, like, but then the thing is, hackers will just buy
a new account.
And so, like, hackers can't be on streamer mode name.
But then, like, a lot of hackers, they just buy a new
account that has 700 link.
It's not that hard because it's, like, $10.
or some shit.
Maybe it's less now, but the fact that he is still alive.
There we go.
Just in case.
I healed that.
I did my best to out heal that.
I think if it was Maga versus Maga, then I think it'd be I
think we need Maga Mirror or some shit.
I don't know.
Maybe it's more expensive now, but it used to be like $10 to
$20 to just buy to buy like an account for people to just
hack on.
But obviously it might be more expensive because they need
to win 750 games.
But even then, people would just like bot it, you know?
They just use bots to Holy shit, there he is.
I can't see you!
Why were you so far out?
Hogg, why are you here?
What?
You need 700 wins.
Holy shit.
Everyone was so far from each other.
I don't even know how how I can position there.
Yeah, it's all up.
Yep.
guys do we not have all i'm trying uh
unlucky all right i'll do one more overwatch and then we
swap games wait actually i need to get rid of the junk rat i
don't even know who underperformed i don't even maybe me but
like i don't even know how what we could do in that
situation maybe the hog because like if he did like a if he
did the maga mirror maybe it would have been better
hey thank you for tier one sub thank you thank you
oh i can press n oh i guess i can but i don't want to
endorse them oh i should ban manga i was just told that Maga
is, like, really strong now.
Oh, right-click to avoid.
Oh, okay.
That's all I know about it.
What?
Wait, I was like, why is he in my death match?
How did he get here?
How is he in?
Oh, he's killing two right now
Oh shit Oh fuck It's worth it It's worth it Of course He's
the one that stood in my trap What is he doing?
What is he doing?
Re-kill.
I'm scared now.
He always hunts me down.
But he doesn't know I'm here unless he's stream sniping.
Alright.
Alright, well, no.
We'll see if they're stream sniping.
Well, no.
I fucking do it!
I do it!
I...
He's dead, I told you, every...
You kill him, he's gonna fuck y'all, I'm free.
I caught him.
I caught Red Ander.
I fucking knew it.
No shame.
Why would he know I was there?
I was like, never moved.
Didn't make any footsteps.
Select your hero.
No shame.
Choose
hero bands.
So toxic.
Madka's bad.
Oh, hero bands?
Oh, we'll let them ban it.
Madka's bad.
I don't need a stream snipe you to kill you.
How about that?
Welcome to reality.
Oh, shit.
I don't play Ana right now, actually.
Defend.
If only I was attack, because I actually really want to play
Ana.
I heard Zen is really good, but I know Zen Mercy is not
enough use, though.
And then Mercy heals pretty ass.
Same with Valeri.
Alright.
Let's play a game.
How much money has this person spent on Mercy?
You have to play Mercy.
No, I go Kiri.
Oh, okay.
Oh, okay, look.
Look at that.
She's willing to swap, though.
Stay sharp.
It's harder to keep you alive when you're distracted.
Alright.
I mean, they're going to go Kiri.
I'm going to swap to Elari.
I really want to play Elari.
Or I will troll!
Ah, yes.
Overwatch.
Never change.
Oh, shit.
Oh, there's the...
I'm a little scared, actually.
I feel safe here, I think.
Where is he?
Oh, I'll use that just in case.
Alright.
Well, at least she's dead.
Where's our other player, anyway?
Oh, where...
Where's our... Oh, there she is.
I was gonna say, I feel like...
This is a 5v5 game, right?
Oh.
Thank you.
Oh, I love.
There you go.
Because I'm not hitting my sleeps.
I need like a little bit of time to hit it.
There's no way we could do anything about that guy.
Oh, my...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, she is so low.
I'm just gonna sit here.
All right, there we go.
All right, I'm alive.
I'm just gonna lie down here.
Oh, Anna.
Whatever they do to you, you're still the same.
I used to be a...
Good Anna player.
So it's still...
No matter what they do to you, at least you still play the
same.
What?
Alright.
Oh, I'll just stay here.
I think he's gonna jump down on me.
I hear him.
Oh.
Alright.
Yeah, I was gonna stay.
There's no way.
I'm okay here nice oh she's fine oh hello all right oh
that's good that's a good shot that's a good up never mind
oh shit okay I didn't think he would peek up.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I didn't think she would peek me there.
That's alright.
Our mercy is still alive.
Yeah, Anna, she's fun to play.
If you know how to play her, she's like pretty decent.
Because like right now, like, no matter what they do with
Anna, she still plays the same.
So, like my knowledge of Anna.
Like, I'm like Lucille.
They changed them so much.
They reworked them so much that I used to be a But my
playstyle, Lucille, is so different from what the new, like,
the new playstyle Lucille is.
I can't, I can't play Lucille the same as I did in the past.
So, like, that's the only, that's the unfortunate part
about.
I really wish I could.
Oh my god, I wanted to alt so badly.
I got booped everywhere.
They haven't reworked her at all, really.
So, like, she pretty much plays the same as usual.
That sucks.
Oh, my God.
I want it to nano, but...
Oh, I missed.
She wouldn't know that.
Yeah.
Just feels...
There we go.
What's wrong is...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna wait for Nano.
With Nano Sojourn.
There you go.
That should kill him.
Alright.
Yeah, she still plays the same.
It's like, after...
Since release, she still plays the same.
So I don't have to ever actually, like, worry about her
playstyle because of it.
Even when I'm stuck, it's fine.
There we go.
There.
Well, we got it.
Careful.
Wait, did everybody die?
Oh, they did.
It's funny that the Symmetra player wanted the Mercy Swap.
Not going for a crit?
I think isn't the bio thing that's worth it more?
I thought the bio was a better investment.
Oh, is she okay?
Oh, I can't see her.
That's fine.
Yeah, double nays should be better.
Yeah, I know.
I was not expecting comms.
Nobody said anything for so long.
Oh, now he plays.
Oh.
Oh, I'm fucking goodbye.
I'll leave.
Domina.
I keep thinking her name is Domina.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Hitting those headshots.
shots yeah but i want to win
i want to win i don't care are you oh jesus i love the
passive aggressiveness here you're so silly
ah good old overwatch good old overwatch
oh i mean she wasn't doing too bad on mercy it helps because
it's like they're also uh they're also they also have a
mercy so it counters each other counter acts going soft do
not speak to me unless you wish to lose your other heart
just feeling it they had a win they're doing winston i now
for gifting a sub and I was like I want a Winton icon I want
a Winton badge it's the only reason why I'm here I saw
Winton and you look at my cute Winton badge Winton I mean it
helps that they also have oh they're going Domina where
Where do I go?
Where does she go?
There he is.
Oh, fuck.
Terran's fine.
I didn't actually need healing.
Do reload, though.
Oh, I can't grenade that.
Ooh.
What?
I've hit what do you mean how did I not hit that's unlucky
oh he's one he's actually one it's all right we almost have
us we're done I
don't know why we're going Hazard.
I was like, Hazard didn't work for them.
So...
He's alive!
He's...
Oh my god, he's still alive.
I'm so fucked up right now.
Oh, he's so low.
I got pooped everywhere.
It's fine.
We have nanoblade.
Wait, I have the cat badge too?
Please.
I'm almost there.
It's not a boy.
There we go.
Oh my god, this is where I died though.
It was okay.
I got the natto played out.
It's okay.
I died for the cause.
All right.
Let me go.
I'm a hero.
All right.
The mercy can go.
Go do your mercy thing.
Oh shit, guess I won't peek.
You
know what, it's fine.
Heroes never die.
Oh shit, maybe heroes do die.
I have
to reload so I hope she lives.
That's unlucky.
It's five.
Wait, how did she sit?
That's good?
Just pretend I actually got the ante on that.
Just, we get to imagine.
What the fuck?
Aw, that would have been cool if I got that.
It would have been so cool.
Oh, Shit.
That was my bad.
Oh, that's crazy mercy.
Why me?
I do, why?
I just, I just got back.
Okay.
I mean, we have nanoblade.
soon-ish i feel like no i was like thinking do i i was like
do i oh my gosh all right i'm stupid damn right you are
all right all right here we go holy let's just use
everything oh my
Guys, guys.
Guys.
Holy shit.
It's okay.
It's all right.
It's just Emory.
Yay!
At least you got me.
It can't hurt you, I'm just like, guys, guys, please,
please, he's right behind me.
Thank you for letting me play Mercy.
Oh, nice.
She can't do more.
Oh, damn.
It was clearly a Mercy VM.
Man, that's my nano right there.
You know what, I'll do one.
I'm...
I enjoyed that Anna play.
I really did.
I enjoyed it.
We'll do another one.
Anna was fun.
Not the part where I got like absolutely like ran at.
But like when I don't get ran at.
It's been fun.
You don't learn anything from my gameplay.
But at least we can have fun.
Ooh, I hear him.
I don't even know what she does, honestly.
I don't know what she...
I just don't know her, what she does.
Is she bad or good?
I don't see anyone playing her.
I assume she's bad.
I think Ana has been...
Ana, no, Mercy had so much rework, but she's so easy to
learn to rework.
But I feel like Ana's like...
She's, like, the only character that has, like, that nothing
really has changed about her to the point where, like, you
can come back.
You haven't, it's like, oh, you don't, you haven't played
Overwatch in, like, years, but you can come back and still
play on a, because she's just, she's very, yeah, she's been
consistent.
She hasn't had any major rework at all.
Mostly, it's just perks.
by everyone all the other supports have had huge reworks
i guess mora too but mora's not really what the fuck what
the what the bye cat that's right i would punch a cat in the
face in game oh my god he scared the shit out of me she fall
down i mean i'll take that only 83 3 HP?
Tanya's fucking pack ever.
Oh, I hear...
There you go.
Oh, I hear Sierra.
Got!
Couldn't catch me.
It works.
Map reduced loss.
Hey, I like the sound of that.
Reduced loss.
Sign me up.
That's fucking right.
Select your hero.
Alright.
Oh,
I'll ban Diva.
And then, I don't know.
Maybe Emory?
Do we have an Emory player?
I'll ban Maga.
Just because fuck that character.
I don't know if we have a Maga player, but I'll ban him.
reduced loss is reduced loss
whoops let's see
all right after this I still have to overwatch today I don't
know I'm just feeling I just feel like playing FPS games
today just feeling the moon just feeling the gaming moon oh
I will I'll play Ana since we're on ride.
You want to play Lari a little bit.
Am I the only GM player in this lobby?
Oh, fuck.
There are no...
I did say what's good to...
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, I need this reduced lot.
Hey.
I might have to swap.
Maybe half a second between me killing the last person.
Oh, no.
That half a second actually matters.
Because it was at two...
meters there's not half a second amount of time for me oh we
should have banned hammond i'll watch it back go for it
thank god he's close it is wow he's close if you steamroll
this entire game then it's so bad
are they okay where's my ryan there he is all right we're
going far left by the way oh he's already behind us
we're five i didn't really care about you we're five i
haven't missed the hatch uh cassidy garden left okay i need
to back oh he's so oh shit he's not healthy anymore yeah oh
my god there's still a cassidy oh my god there's still a
cassidy i have to reload i to reload oh that's unlucky oh my
god i'm done fucking oh what is going on what is going on
What is going on?
I'm just being juggled everywhere.
It's fine.
It's still...
We got the point for so long.
It's fine.
I have nano.
I'm not hitting my sleeps at all.
That'll be fine, right?
He's so healthy.
Holy shit, I think he's fine.
Oh!
There you go.
Okay, I thought I would get...
Okay, I saw my...
I saw what you were doing, Mora!
I saw!
Alright, at least we have...
I saw you, Mora.
I saw the fucking white click.
Okay, we have, we have lots.
I can.
I'm just gonna use nano for this.
I'll be balling.
Balling, balling, balling.
Nice.
Go, go.
It's hot!
Oh.
Never mind.
okay i mean that's that's okay with me i mean they're all
back okay i mean that's fine with me
zoning on i'm on the ball i'm gonna shadow early maybe okay
on a low one leading out
Oh, ball and thing.
Holy fuck.
The double stun.
Oh, Sarah Lobe weeding out.
One HP, one HP on it.
You got that.
There you go.
Nice.
What the fuck was that?
Okay.
Why are we exaggerating?
It's a big difference.
It's a big difference, man.
Here we go.
I've played a couple West.
Wild games.
I get it.
I'm a tank.
I swing a hammer around.
So it's not like too crazy.
But like.
Fucking wild games.
It's pretty bad.
I think I'm going even, honestly.
I win this and I'm positive.
You know what is bad?
You.
A tank.
Oh, whoa.
Your attitude.
Damn.
Hard.
Our cast is doing really well.
Hmm.
I think otherwise.
And if one of our teammates starts shitting the ball.
Yes, I am in GM right now.
GM5.
Is Juno so mad?
I have no idea.
Today's the first day I've dated.
Sorry, I'm sorry.
Oh.
When did I ever say it?
Whoa, sorry.
I don't know what our moral was doing there.
Not the best situation to be right now.
That's five.
Oh, one called really one.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
Emory one.
The reload.
We're so healthy!
Okay.
I think it's just a ball.
Uh...
Are they okay?
Emory low as well.
I'll be with fire.
me and you emery me and you
oh fuck i don't know what my idea plan was for that uh see
her on point right now no she can't follow up three load uh
left side left side yes left side me and you right oh i
missed my fire strike oh i'm okay that's fine no i'm
shooting that shield
Oh, they're like ball is always low
I'm doing a little drawing Right No No No All right
All right I don't know why I'm right Charging the four
people But you know what Sometimes just has to charge
sometimes it calls for him no our ride is so fucking dead
unless all right emery this is your time to shine emery you
and me oh imagine okay maybe not maybe not yeah maybe not
and ball sierra is the best there's no way look i just want
to ult or emery but he's so scared i would have to just walk
forward emery please and there's no reason to be scared meet
my nano you're uh best else in the game oh my god jesus
christ oh
There we go.
Here we go.
I feel like I'm getting harassed right now.
I need to use this to help myself.
All right.
I'm trying to...
You know what?
Everybody's fully...
Oh.
I've healed everyone.
We used every ult, but I've...
Are you sure about that?
Wait, I already have 74?
Let's see.
That...
That's crazy.
Guys, I've already have...
I'm already 74 ult charge.
That's actually insane.
I'm wrapping around back.
Oh, okay.
c9 forgot something critical nice yeah that's not very nice
you know my 25 bank the fact that i got 74 right at like in
just one fight start today no the fact that it like our cast
is good our cast is aim was really it i was not expecting to
have already be close to my i don't think anybody Yes, so
you're aware.
Oh, that's me.
You did average.
That's me.
Six, man.
Like, this wasn't a 40 and 0 fucking performance.
This is what happens when we're on the East Coast.
Let's calm down, pal.
Let's calm down.
Where are we at?
Oh, we are.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Good.
Somebody voted for me.
That's not me.
That's good.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I can actually get GM4.
Fuck.
Do we risk?
Actually.
Oh my, guys, if I win the next game, I get GM4.
Let's do it.
There is a chance.
You don't understand, guys.
I could beat GM4 if I win one more.
All right, let's... What is the challenger score right now?
The leaderboard.
There's no... Oh, wait, 20.
We're at season 2, right?
America.
There's no way.
Okay, 2000.
I was like, hey, 2000.
than 200.
Yeah, it's all right.
It's gonna take a while.
Well, it's played a win.
That's the thing about Challenger Score now.
It's literally played a win.
It's like, it just depends on how much you play.
So, like, technically, I could be, look at this,
technically, oh, no.
Technically, I could be, if we look at rank-wise I'm already
top 500 rank-wise like I'm here because like Masters 5
there's someone that's played Jesus how many games have you
played oh Jesus Christ didn't this season just started how
many games is that holy shit guys this guy should have
played 24 hours of didn't the season come out like two days
ago or a week ago Oh my god.
This guy already played 24 out.
At least 24 hours.
Boop, boop.
Alright, let's go.
It's just the only benefit of being higher rank is that you
gain more challenger score.
That's the only benefit.
Hello, little guy.
Oh.
Aww.
He's so scared!
Fuck this cat.
Oh, it's a tracer tracer fight.
Tracer v tracer.
I think tracer 1v1 is so stupid to watch in general.
Because it's like the constant blinking.
I feel like I get cross-eyed.
That's right.
I don't honor your 1v1s.
I hate watching this.
I hate watching Tracer 1v1s the most.
Oh, he's so lucky.
I have to reload.
Oh, they gave her 5 more HP.
I don't know.
Tracer is so hard to play in general.
I used to be a Tracer player.
I like playing Tracer in the past because it's like
tracking.
But, like, I hated 1v1ing on Tracer.
Oh, my God, I'm whiffing.
But I think Tracer 1v1 is just so dumb.
I'm, like, whiffing really hard.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
You know, like, no, when you can't shoot, you shake your...
Shake your hat a little bit.
There you go.
Oh, let me double-check something.
Yeah.
Here, you can have the free kill.
Just double-checking something.
Hey, hey.
Lifeweaver versus lifeweaver?
That's it.
All right, give me a sec.
Oh, never mind.
I don't want to.
One push.
I'm going to be that one guy.
Oh, okay.
The other one guy won.
What does it mean?
The other one guy won the vote.
My bad diva.
I mean, it's Mr. Berlter.
So, Diva's pretty bad.
Veneta?
I mean, yeah.
Well, we're banning Veneta.
I'll put Zarya in here, too.
Alright, just in case, like, the Veneta ban doesn't go
through, we at least have Zarya.
The counter one guy.
Yeah, one.
One guy number two.
It's nice, I can do long streams again.
I was like...
You know, with the concert prep and everything, I couldn't
do long streams because I had to make sure my voice is okay.
But now I can chill again.
I don't really want to...
What if I go...
Oh, never mind.
The Mercy is actually good on defense, though, so...
I don't have to worry about, like, you know, being like, Oh,
shit, I have to...
I have to cut my stream short because I need to go work on
stuff right now.
No, I literally everything was put on hold because of the
concert.
Like I had so many projects like planned in the works before
I had to go full on with the concert.
Like, like WrestleTuber was put on hold.
Like literally WrestleTuber was put on hold.
But planning for that for like two months because of it.
So like I had to put everything on pause.
And then like other stuff, other projects I had behind it.
scenes like you know birthday stuff like literally
everything was put on hold
i should i'm gonna help our our monkey our anna will help
the monkey
they're on us five
really there you go
now now i don't have to worry
I hope...
Don't worry, I hope our monkey will be okay though.
I don't know.
Alright, that's fine.
Armory's got this.
Whoa!
Oh, I don't know what that does.
But I didn't like that there was a giant stick on me.
Like, scared me a little.
Let's see.
Oh my gosh, she lives because of me.
welcome it lets her auto aim on you oh well good thing she
died before that happens
all right you just gotta have to wait and see tracer there
you go me and you they need up i don't think so they're five
Okay, I thought the other Jim Lee thought the echo was gonna
hard push Yada.
You could have played monkey last game.
Damn, the call out.
I wonder what happened there.
He has to be one of those guys that avoided the monkey and
then now he's actually doing stuff.
Tell as old as time.
Holy shit.
Our Ana's fine, right?
Don't worry, Ana!
Don't worry!
Oh my god!
Ana, I do need you to move on a little bit.
Alright, our Winston has all of it though.
You know what?
Okay.
Let's go!
Train is there!
Oh my god.
Let's go, Anna!
You and me!
Is there somebody over there?
Nice.
Are they okay over there?
Winthon!
Let's go, Winthon!
Alright.
Oh,
I don't want us.
Holy healthy.
Never mind.
Okay.
That was scared.
It's okay.
Me and you, Tracer.
Wait.
He's so low.
It's worth it.
What is it?
Yay!
Winton.
Oh hey, I was the only one with me and the Winton.
Both have, I think, a lot.
Good hold, good hold.
See, I told you.
I told you.
I just need a couple of games, guys.
It's all coming back to me.
I just needed a, like, the first game was very rough.
The first game was incredibly rough.
i progressed like it's all slowly coming back to me also why
thank you for the 100 videos thank you thank you that's it
thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you thank you
went on
yeah we need more characters like went on
i have a went on funko pop Are you disappointed in me or are
you proud?
You know, like, I...
Can you TP top for me?
Oh, damn.
Okay, you said that.
You say.
But anyway, so, you know, I've always wanted a Funko Pop.
And then I told, like, my event manager, I was like, can you
make...
Because, like, can you make that happen?
And then she was like, I don't think it's possible anymore.
like why he's like he's like uncle pop is bankrupt right now
so like it's no longer possible
they're saying like uncle pop is now like mega is like
bankrupt so they're not they're not taking any new contracts
anymore and i got really sad because i was like put all the
love guys like it was like apparently a previous contract so
it was like more so of like previous like obligations that
they had to do so we're here yeah we
did it went done we win with went on oh my god a poor Look
at him, girl.
Oh my god, he's monkeying around.
Look at him.
He's wintoning around.
That's me!
I avoided it for myself.
Fuck, of course.
Wait.
No one wants to talk.
I didn't want to say anything.
Oh, shit.
He's dancing.
No one wants to talk.
I joined the match chat.
All right, did I get it?
Grandmaster 4!
That's so I can go.
Oh, okay, I thought I got him.
I thought I did something bad.
And I was like, your voice has just been muted.
And I was like, what did I say?
I literally thought I did something bad.
It looked like one of those, like, you have been chat bad.
Some shit.
Oh, nice.
All right.
guys let's play rivals now i got gm4 i just don't know if i
some of you were asking are you gonna be in the marvel
rivals uh vtuber tournament i don't know but just in case
because i haven't played in a while i just gotta do this as
a precaution uh all
right sorry gomez was like 30 minutes ago was like hey we
can do and i was like it's too late never mind i was like
unless you want to play rivals with me and yeah all right i
guess i'm i'm forcing him back the rivals all right let me
figure out the sound settings for that
Let's see, what is my...
It's in Marvel.
I hate that it goes onto the other screen.
Okay, 14.8.
Alright, I was practically almost the same.
Hmm.
Alright.
Back to Rivals at Go.
Just because I didn't yet know what the fuck meta is.
I don't think I can do the bands.
I said, they asked me if I wanted...
I think I had to set...
I said this before, but they were like, do you, uh, uh, do
you want to come back?
And I was like, I'll come back if I don't, if I don't have
to be captain.
So, like, don't expect me to do the bad lines.
I just didn't want to be captain.
That's, that's like my only, my only requirement.
Let's see.
Oh my God.
on my friends list are live on here.
Let's see.
I just want to chill.
Like, I've been so stressed out over everything.
So I really, I just didn't want to be captain for the next
one.
But I don't know yet if I'm in it.
But if I have to be, if I have to be it, if I'm actually in
it, then I have to know what the fuck meta is.
Because I don't know.
I haven't played in a while.
At least went out of the, oh, I need to wait for the
shaders.
Because I don't know what People play right now Oh yeah, the
category Uh Luckily There's drops also Uh Eloteric
I'm bad
Elotericizing There's There you go.
Yeah.
I just, I just, just don't like triple support at all.
I'm just not a huge fan of it.
Okay, let me see what I...
Do I wait for you or we...
Or I queue at one.
Bum, bum...
it'll be like one minute all right one minute that's enough
time for him to get funky i don't know i like that he
blushes too because that's a fucking shark like what not
because he's twerking yeah but then the like you know how
like the dog does the funky among us dance you know but he's
not blushing the fact that he's blushing not because he's
wearing a maid outfit yes but I put him in that outfit so
that's different all I'm saying is that the fact that he's
blushing changes everything
yes because it's a cute it's like when you dress up your dog
you know
I like Jeff more as an industry plant than Luna I still find
it funny how like he literally existed in like what like
only a couple of comics he doesn't have his actual he
doesn't really have his own comics he was most likely a side
character thing um and and then like now he's just
everywhere I think the funniest is just the whole the blind
boxes thing where they finally released the Marvel Rivals
blind box and it's like uh it was like Luna's nose
Spider-Man Thor and then 10 Jeffs 10 Jeffs in 10 different
outfits Amalie thank you for the raid I hope you had a great
stream Amalie um don't worry we're playing rivals right now
but we had a really great really good stream lagging a
little in a while.
It's because he's being too funkier right now.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
But yeah, I hope you have a fun stream over on your end.
Oh, I'm not lagging a bit.
That's weird.
Let me check my...
He was getting too funky.
The Jeff dance.
Yeah.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
What was she streaming earlier, guys?
Winrose?
Oh, isn't that the pirate game?
Right?
That's the pirate one.
Yeah.
I wanted to play that game, but I feel like I wish it was
like, I wish it was like Zia Thieves, where you could have a
giant server, and then you all like, because it's like what,
the maximum you can have is eight players.
It would be so fun if you could have, like, a giant-ass
server with people just fucking plundering.
Let's host a big pirate server.
Just, like, sea of thieves.
I wanted to try it out, too.
Yeah, so it's, like, make it, like, rust-like.
Oh, it's still early access?
Oh, that's...
That means that it could happen in the future.
It could add in the future.
What the fuck, you Celestial?
Yeah, the max we have is 8 right now.
No, I won't do that to them.
I want to play there naturally with the new update.
First picks widow.
Imagine doing so.
I want to play.
I know that's so fun with the new update.
Actually, I don't think I played...
I did play rank.
I didn't play rank since the new season came out.
I just played the early axis.
I just remembered.
I've only...
I didn't play yet.
Alright, drops in both sides.
Alright, there.
You get a drop and you get a drop and you get a drop.
Did I change my cat?
I did.
I just gotta be sure.
Drops everywhere.
Why are we ban Penny Parker?
Is she that good?
I don't know.
Maybe new meta.
She's good now.
Like I said, I haven't played new season yet.
This is the first time I played new season.
So I have no idea what's going on.
We're better skin.
Disco pop, cherry delight.
Cool summer.
I should like Disco pop.
the most out of all of them i just think luna does not have
a lot of good skins she might be an industry plaid but like
i don't play this game i don't hate i don't really like her
forced on rocket immediately what are you kidding me i'm
saving this game bro this game is sick of you i have four
dps players on my team immediately dude i don't want to
please tank i'll just dps rocket
Welcome back to rival Super Gomez!
Welcome back!
Alright, there we go.
The duck shaking, duck with cigarette shaking his head.
PNG.
Oh wait, GIF.
Alright, here we go.
Animated PNG.
Sorry, a.
Dot APNG.
Huh.
Classic.
Why are you adding 7 TV?
One day.
Oh shit.
Wait, that was fantastic though.
Not that bad.
Oh.
Oh, why is everybody so...
Wait, is Cloak bad?
Actually...
You know, let's go in this so I can like at least protect
myself a little bit more.
Let's see...
Oh, don't worry, I'll go in this for you.
Just I'll pull out my pants for the rest of everyone.
I appreciate it.
I don't appreciate you.
Damn.
I went tank for you.
I could have just went fucking third DPS.
Oh, I would have rather have that.
Oh, shit.
I'm just talking about me.
I'll just switch to fucking Black Widow if you want to be a
fucking player.
What the fuck?
Why is everybody mad already?
Just don't play this game if you're going to be a bitch.
Wow!
Everyone's so mad already!
Oh my god!
I think you don't know that.
At least...
Everyone's so mad.
Everyone...
yes i don't think we're gonna win this game yet i have a
feeling oh he got frozen oh whoops let's go it's fine oh
it's no longer fine wait they double two
It's fine.
It's okay.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
They also doubled.
I wish there was.
I'm really cute.
It's alright.
It's like I said, it's always the first game, guys.
It's random.
They give it to Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Samra, they give it the videos.
It's okay.
Roll Q.
Oh boy.
It's all right.
First game is always bad.
Second game is where it starts.
I want a roll Q.
If there's roll Q, there's no more triple support.
Think about that, guys.
Think about this, guys.
Roll Q equals no triple support.
That's it.
That's the risk I'm willing to take.
It will be worth it.
It'd be so worth it, guys.
So worth it without triple.
Alright.
It's okay.
I might have to go rock it.
May not be as okay as I would like.
Holy fuck, he was one.
I'm sad.
He was actually one.
There's no way you're gonna let me die there.
What the fuck?
I hear...
Is he gonna be okay?
He's gonna be okay, right?
I hope so.
I can't kill you.
Ooh, unless I can!
That Spider-Man's gonna fuck me up, though, I have a
feeling.
That's Spider-Man.
He's looking for me.
But what if he doesn't know where I am?
He's gonna know where I am now.
Under that.
There is no way I live that.
There is no way.
Well, the guy...
that was our other healer.
Now has six kills.
Oh, hey.
At least some...
Look, one of our DPS sucked up his ego.
Let's go, guys.
He's gonna do like... He's gonna do that Spider-Man all up.
I can feel it.
There you go.
I need to reload, though.
Are we okay?
Because I'm just clapping.
There we go.
He's coming for it.
Getting ready.
He's like...
What was that spot?
Oh, nice.
Yeah, no.
All right.
Spider-metal.
Any second now.
He's gonna Spider-metal.
It's gonna come.
Right here.
Oh, I have the ult for it though.
That's right.
I got it.
That's right!
I got it!
Any minute now.
Get predicted!
Oh no.
That's not good for me.
I'm like, where?
I don't like it here.
Get me out of here.
Oh, no.
Yeah, add roll cue for just support.
Honestly, not a bad idea.
Roll cue for just support.
Nothing else.
Oh.
Not a bad idea.
All right Where oh care We kill the low-key bro Yeah
We're having a limit yeah the two support limit like how
Overwatch has a two-take limit you play open queue Music
makes people happy that actually would be a good a good a
good addition to the game.
Yeah, it's just support.
There's no roll queue.
It's just a limit.
Like the maximum you need to add for support is just two.
When Adam and Ultron would be gutted, then just give them
more heals.
So then they can work as a...
They can work as a flex support.
Just rework them.
Yeah.
Rework Adam and Ultron.
the battle starts in five four three two one you can
literally yeah you can literally adjust what about triple
dps then doesn't really matter if you have just adjust the
numbers honestly
i think like it's just triple support kills the game like
makes me like super bored in general i guess it doesn't kill
the game for me, I just get very bored.
Blame.
Oh my god.
You got fucked up.
Yo, cap the boy.
Yay.
It's just boring.
I find triple support just very boring to play with and
against.
Like, I don't care if my team goes triple support.
I just find it a very boring comp.
Because it makes a like super slow
Alright Oh my god Oh, she lives There you go She's alive
Oh, I hear someone behind me Oh, it's just a fantastic
There's nobody
Okay, oh shit, what the fuck What the fuck?
Oh my god, what was going on?
Behind!
They were everywhere!
It's fine, everybody's still alive.
Everything, everybody's alive.
Everyone is so healthy!
I'm gonna assume my...
Oh.
I'm gonna assume my Inviswalt first.
I'm betting it all on her.
Oh my god, oh my god, all right, that's fine.
Watch this, I'm gonna, oh, and then the mag will be like,
fear!
Oh, unless...
Oh, I forgot damage boosted.
It's been so long.
Alright, invisible woman.
There it is.
Not me, though.
Not me.
Oh, not me, though.
No fear.
Yay!
So, do I need to even explain why I'm a Lord Magic has a
Lord Envis?
Damn, we're home.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I think Overwatch changed him.
He brought the Overwatch to rival.
He brought Overwatch.
What's a rivals, guys?
What does he mean by wrong?
It's just not toxic.
It's called passion.
You'll never be the same what overwatch does to a person.
I'm gonna go pee all the way back guys
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Who am I gonna be?
banish from this match.
Any anger from those I guess?
And then maybe the amateur
Safe made it.
All right.
Oh, no Luna.
It's fine.
I'll play Black play.
I'm sorry, Sayu.
I know you always tell me to pick you.
But I really don't think support Deadpool is the way to go.
I think support Deadpool might be pretty ass.
Yeah, here it, Evangel.
Oh, wait.
Is it tomorrow?
I think our first guest announcement for the concert is
tomorrow.
Let me know.
Yeah!
Oh, I'm so excited.
I'm so excited.
It's starting.
And then after that, I think it's like every two to three
days, we announce the next guest.
Yeah, every three days, yeah, every three days, we announce
a new guest.
Tomorrow!
I'm super excited.
Yeah.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Uh...
We'll go in this.
It's a cooler dokey.
This could be cooler, Doki.
What the fuck are we always talking about?
I know what you're saying.
You're like mumbling.
Yeah, he is mumbling.
Yeah, I am mumbling.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm defense.
Slightly taller, Doki.
Please let him be cool, Doki.
Doki.
It's C4 Doki.
Niki Doki.
Honestly, I'm glad it turned...
It sounded good.
I was so worried because they were like, we need you to
re-record.
Because apparently my timing for it was so bad.
Like the recording timing for it.
Because like I said, I didn't have time to actually like
learn the song.
So I was trying my best to sing it.
Even though I was like super unfamiliar.
That was one.
them literally though so i'm glad and then i send them the
new takes and they're like yeah that's good now i was like
yay thank god
oh i should have pulled it back your heels
all right all right pull shirt back
Oh.
Thank you.
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh, okay.
All right.
He's...
He might be...
Yeah, oh, that's unlucky.
Got two.
Oh, I fucked up the...
Back up.
Oh, please.
Okay, now I don't have...
Alright, we have him.
Yay!
Oh, he was so low.
Dude, that's unlucky.
12, 3.
Not for sure.
Alright.
I need a...
I heal.
I hear some... Oh, that's just a tree.
I was gonna say, I hear people...
Oh!
Not good!
Alright, we're gonna fall back a bit.
Oh, never mind.
You guys got it.
Alright, good again!
Good again!
We're all good, Paul.
Almost that vault again.
I didn't have siloed, right?
I didn't even know when he was on siloed.
Matt
Fuck that guy No, you know what?
No, you're right Fuck that guy in particular I agree Oh no I
was so close up It's okay
We're gonna be funny And we had No, you're gonna have to do
it I don't know I know you have your ult.
Oh, you might be able to walk it.
You're gonna have to go quick though.
I'm literally...
All right, he's stalling.
He's stalling!
Oh!
I went to the new area.
That's unlucky.
Fuck that.
Just gotta map it.
Can I hear the sh- oh, that's our shark.
switch too give it one more push i have an idea whoa what's
your idea fellow man black pan there okay oh i haven't seen
a when you just play black cat instead of black panther
oh no yeah holy i'm just gonna
Oh my god, he's so low.
I'm diving into those right now.
On their support.
I had to.
Okay, we didn't have to do that, though.
Oh, that's a little bit too many of us.
Too many of us.
I go BP and then they go the better character.
Where's the better character?
GG.
You know any other guys?
I switched to Jetman.
They go...
They're gonna die.
I'm on their support.
They went thing?
Wait, oh my, they were so scared of the dives.
That's funny.
Oh.
Dude, I went...
I went BP and then they go B.
You people not on counterplay.
That is counterplay.
Wait, but that is counterplay.
What do you mean?
But counter-swapping is counter-play.
You know, they move their mouse and aim it up.
Natural, yeah.
Shit.
Oh,
you guys double jump.
Oh, you guys double jump.
Oh.
I know the thing is cool.
And...
Oh!
Okay, how is she still alive?
Okay, there you are.
I was gonna say, I fucking...
Oh my god.
He had a...
He had a whole shield too.
That's right!
Oh, he still lives.
Is he okay?
He's gonna be okay.
Where are you aiming at?
Oh.
Oh, he has shield now.
whoa where am i holy shit he's still trying to find me oh my
god oh my god he ran past me thank god
all right that's fine he didn't know he didn't know oh my
god he knows now he knows now he knows now he knows now oh
fuck okay Do you get anybody in that off?
Oh,
he lied.
Our Jeff lied.
He said no.
He lied.
I know what he said.
He actually lied.
I'm gonna die here.
He actually said no.
No!
We all saw.
We saw.
All right,
I'm gonna say my luck.
I hear a...
No, I have this.
There we go.
I am.
All right.
People loudly say it ain't so.
But all of all of dragons saw what you did, Jeff.
The fact that he said, no.
Did you get anyone?
I know what you are.
But cat, do you two want something?
Thank you.
I'll just push the card.
I mean, it's bad because I am a support.
Um...
I think it'll be fine, right?
Okay.
Yeah, my silo's gonna be fine.
Oh, I wanted to pull him back.
He definitely has ult, so I'm gonna be careful.
He's fine.
He's so healthy!
Oh my god.
I don't know how.
Is it five?
Oh my god, okay, that's not five.
It's not five.
It's no longer five.
Oh no.
Guys, there's so many things happening in the corner right
now.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god, he's pulling it.
He's pulling the...
He's pulling the Star Lord.
Nice, push, push, push, push, push.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I have to reload.
I have to reload.
That's unlucky.
We win next fight.
Yeah, we have...
We got all our health next fight.
No, we'll probably use you.
Oh, please.
He's so low.
I've been healing for so long.
He will.
I pulled him back too!
Oh.
He's going.
There we go.
Oh.
That was a good-ass pull from...
Wait, guys!
Guys!
Hey, there is a...
There is a...
There is... Alright, you know...
Yay!
My death was meaningless.
At least I died for the cause.
I died for what I believe in.
That's right.
Plan.
Evelyn baited him on purpose.
Oh, nice.
We both got the...
We both got trusty sidekick.
Let's fucking go.
We didn't almost lose it.
It all went according to plan.
Oh, any new skins?
Oh, yeah, it's the Gala thing.
Oh, yeah.
What was it?
Deep analysis.
Index rule.
Okay.
What's the vote thing?
Do we vote after?
Are you new stuff?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, yeah.
There it is.
Let's get that in.
That's a good skin.
Alright.
Next game.
Oh, it's in the Gala Pass menu?
I'll check that up later.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
I don't know.
I don't play Luna.
I don't want to play DPS Luna.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Hope I'm not behind in any work stuff.
With this long stream.
Actually, I can just check chat.
Nope.
All right.
I don't want to do anything anyway.
What is my schedule tomorrow?
Today is Friday.
I have two streams tomorrow.
Okay.
All right, two streams tomorrow.
Are the only person that's lobby not using stream remote?
There's, um, okay.
Yeah, no one wants to talk to him too.
Yeah, I actually am.
I guess they're all losers.
Oh, I'm not OTP.
I'm sorry.
No.
Okay.
You see, not as vidim?
100% you can't play any other thing.
Oh, no.
This is straight up.
Ah, bah, bah, bah.
Ah.
Bango, thank you for the biddies.
Thank you.
You're killing such a...
Kill it.
Nikkei 3.5 line version.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Like I said, I was very surprised.
I was very nervous.
Like I said earlier, I was very nervous about it.
So I'm glad everything turned out okay in the end.
I was hoping that I did not sound the worst out of
everybody.
And I didn't.
It all worked out.
I was very worried.
I mean, I was very lucky that the person that I was
replacing had the easiest song.
I was very lucky with that that they had the easiest song
out of the entire set list because everyone else was like,
or like, or like doorlight, you know, you know what I'm
saying?
But they also their songs are very long too.
I had two verses and it was like one it was like three like
three to four notes
Okay Oh, my...
They're running triple.
Oh, baby.
Our first triple support game.
And...
Aw, that's unlucky.
And tank pool, too?
Holy shit.
They want... You know what?
They want this bad.
I...
Let- I will not blame them for that.
They really want this.
They really want a win.
And they literally need- They need this win.
Tankful and triple support with Ultron.
I do not blame them.
Honestly.
Holy shit.
They definitely have, I'll let the Invis all first.
We made our Spider-Man swap the Panther.
Oh, I love to heal.
Oh, there you go.
I trusted her with my...
Give me a sec.
I really want to live.
All right.
All right, oh, there's the second up.
There it is.
Goodbye.
Oh, I hit that really?
I think I made I should have kept my ult there, but I feel
like we would have died I feel like I would have died I only
did it because I felt like I would have died if I didn't
know that But maybe I should have been more...
I should have not been very selfish.
Oh.
Got a little bit selfish there.
Their Groot is better than our Groot.
I will say that.
I think their Groot is better.
It's okay, Groot!
It's okay!
I think I got you!
I think I saved your life!
Oh my god.
Please, Groot, take damage.
So I can heal.
Our teammate disconnected?
Oh no.
Oh no, we had to lose one.
We were, it was going too good for too long.
It really was.
It was going too good for too long.
It had to happen.
And then the Groot all here.
Goodbye.
Hi everybody.
Wait, he's one.
I'll be honest, I don't even know the way it'll leave her.
I don't know.
I think the Moon Knight fucked up his ult.
It should have killed us.
Unless they nerfed the Moon Knight ult, that should 100%
kill us.
That's why I was so surprised.
I think if it was deeper, it would have killed us there.
There you go.
Oh, he's not living that.
If only we had a second tank.
Might be.
Oh, nice.
He fucked up.
Oh.
All right.
Go, Groot!
Go!
Oh, I have to reload.
Oh, no.
Groot, no!
Oh, no!
I'm just gonna die on point.
It is a lot harder to heal, get a supporter when we're
missing a second tank.
I will say that.
I think that's the same.
Wasn't that the same guy?
Like, BM in the beginning?
That's how badly he won.
See, that's how badly the other team won.
He wanted it.
He wanted it so badly.
That he had to DDoS.
Like that's how much he wants this they want this win
All right, I'm so healthy right now
Hello guys.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh hello everybody.
Hello everyone Oh, maybe we'll...
Oh, I mean...
They're like, wait, we're not winning even with triple
support and tank put.
We gotta send in.
We gotta send in the fucking PayPal.
We need this so bad.
The current score is...
That's how bad I'm the MVP.
That's how badly they won it.
No, we're trying to have fun.
Yeah, I know.
Also, I didn't hear what they said.
Did they roast me?
Or did they, are they like, just like say something?
Oh, I don't know.
I think he just left.
oh I think it very beginning he just said this is GM lobby
that's right he said trying to make a joke and then they got
they got a little pressed he said you can't make it in
either rivals or overwatch I heard it I said I can't make
either rivals or overwatch hold on but this person is on a
gm account sitting and playing the game and leaving when
they're not happy while i'm currently getting paid in
overwatch so what what kind of yeah what do you mean i can't
make it overwatch yeah
i didn't start the fire but she didn't start the fire
That's right, I'm here to rage fade.
The field of flames.
But maybe I did start the fire.
What did you do?
I kept it burning.
I'm gonna go to the thing that take a lot of skill.
He didn't start the fire.
But no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh yeah, actually not gonna forfeit.
I'm fucking for- FFing.
Fuck this shit.
That's right.
I'm gonna do it.
No,
no, we're doing that.
No, we're doing that.
Let's go Let's go Yeah
Yeah You better be sorry We weren't gonna win this there
they literally went triple support They went triple support
tank pool and then the moment we had a chance against them
our guy left the pave they're like we're not winning with
the full meta comp we might as well we're like it's time to
pull out the third card PayPal the enemy team like I can't I
believe it.
The paid actor left.
That's crazy.
The moment they're like, oh my god, none of this is working.
Let me hit up the PayPal real quick.
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine Alright, here we go.
All that for 20 points.
Now, who am I gonna banish from this?
this match.
Wait.
I'm being dragged here without my will.
Why are you in Celestia?
My dude.
You have free will to say no.
I just haven't played since.
can't check right now i gotta like wait till the game's over
yeah when did they when did they start when did deadpool
release uh yeah i remember let the record be showed like it
was he asked to do win overwatch after stream sniping me let
the record show and then i was like i play where i was now
if you want to join me and he's he consented and with his
free will said yes let the record show where is my what does
people call would i like type actually type the record out
what are they called again the type right there.
100%.
Ah, bro, let's go.
We win the shit.
Easy.
The stenographer.
Read it back to me.
Well, we're still fine.
Pretty good.
So he has zero excuse.
We all saw.
100.
Oh, you still watch, uh, MRI?
Yeah, I gotta support the boys.
Of course, yeah, it makes sense to me, guys.
All right, here we go.
No, that's not even a joke.
Oh, fuck.
Watch this.
Watch that bald guy.
Literally.
Oh, wait, wait, actually.
Go watch this, guys.
Did you see that?
Hold my again!
Okay, okay, it didn't matter.
Sorry, sorry, did you guys watch?
I know I said don't watch it, but did you guys watch it
again?
Did you guys rewatch it after?
Oh my god, there's a lot.
Something tells me they killed us.
Something tells me that I need another support.
six i'm so low i might need a stronger support
all right is reset here that die was went too hard white fox
works so tell me how that works oh you like carico carico
but stronger oh yeah i don't know about that one but i'll
think it works okay i need to save him And then now I can
give it.
Oh, I'm lucky.
Please, please, please.
Oh, please.
Oh, Oh, no, wait, where are my teammates?
No!
Let the devil go!
What do we do?
Why did everyone run away from me?
The Groot...
I ulted and then the Groot ran away.
What do I do in that situation?
Ways when I want to go Punisher.
I don't even...
Oh, it's for Punisher.
I think it will be...
Oh, it's much better if I go Punisher.
Okay, they need to stop going.
I'm really pissed off at that They I will say they really
really need to stop They need to stop going behind walls.
I Either someone needs to shoot the wall or they gotta stop
staying behind the wall There's nothing I can do.
I'm just a I'm just a kpop star I
I'm just a kpop singer or or we get off get the fuck off
white fox
goodbye everybody goodbye everybody I don't think I think
our team is really bad I'm making a comeback Or we run
triple.
Oh, that was a really bad...
Oh my god, finally, it stopped.
The snowball finally stopped.
I'm sorry, did...
Did Duda just get invincibility?
Oh, how did that live, bro?
What the hell?
Wait, no, she got invincibility.
Oh, yeah, it's a new change they did, I think.
What does he say Fox?
Why does she type Fox?
Is he going to Fox first?
You're not wrong.
I'm going to have to do this.
Well, here we go.
Oh, here we go.
There we go.
I don't know why she type Fox, but She uses Fox next round.
Fox.
She better be letting me build up.
Oh, she's stupid.
She's stupid.
This player, this player's stupid.
She has full up.
And she's like, I will keep healing.
Okay, she needs to keep healing.
Oh, that's a lot of, uh, that's...
Ooh.
Guys You gotta kill them a little too fast.
I couldn't get my resets.
Ooh.
My bad, my bad, my bad.
Oh, no.
Hey guys.
A little bit, maybe a little bit too much.
A little bit too much.
Alright, I hope she...
I guess I'll slowly walk past.
Oh, I guess I'll just die on point.
That's all good.
I wonder if it'd be cool if we had one more out there.
Oh, they got Google.
I don't know.
Our Fox player is...
Not...
Oh,
he didn't build up.
Oh, he's one HP.
Yeah.
I am...
I think if our white fox was not white fox could be more
winnable.
I think we just needed more heals.
Like white fox is good but like not against that.
What'd you call it?
They're double.
Nah bro I was getting in my ass took because they have a
venom with them.
Can't kill them.
Let's see.
I can touch them.
lucky you know i got this like big you know let's see also
it did not help that our team was not did not shoot the
walls or played behind the walls i i just literally see
everybody behind walls and i'm like i swear to god i swear
to god i don't know i didn't play after the changes i don't
know who's like better as a anti-dive anymore randa got
removed what do they do though
grounded yeah like on his uh shift i think the punch is that
it and i mean he does more damage now like you do more
damage click and oh yeah it would have been nice that we had
support on i just don't with her i don't with our white fox
hear that don't with you i know what i'm avoiding wait what
is this right i know who i'm avoiding soon.
2.
What?
Guangzhou?
Guangzhou.
I think it was Guangzhou.
No, no, it's Guangzhou.
Let him know.
I hope you get your next game, you get another white fox
player and they play like you.
And then you have to play Luna with that white fox.
That's right You serious okay
Now you'll be I feel the sure you can let it go now never
let it go Like one shots squishy when you altered them
before Oh my god they got it Oh my god the
Oh shit Oh shit Oh fuck I'm alive There we go I don't know
how I live that That was crazy I'm alive Feels very good
It would be a shame If he dives me
Unless...
Yeah, I was going right side.
Trying to third person this shit right now.
He's gonna fall back right side.
He's gonna cut him off.
Oh god, I don't have anything.
I don't have anything.
Oh my god, what do I do?
We had a white...
I have to be fair, it wasn't punishable.
I'll just use
it.
Fuck it.
I'll clap just for the sake of it.
I gotta clap.
I don't know.
See if I can hook one.
Oh, I thought I would have got that.
Whoa.
I heal you, you heal me.
Wouldn't be great if we had a white...
We have six of us.
Oh, shit.
Did I just see their venom get a full-blown, like...
His health didn't even have lines anymore.
I legitimately thought...
Oh, wait, they buffed his armor.
I legitimately thought our white fox would have ulcered
that, but I feel like at this point, like I should never...
I shouldn't rely on anything anymore.
I...
All right, there we go.
Let's go, everyone.
Yay!
Oh, we did it!
Let's go, everyone!
We did it!
No, I don't believe in my wife, Foxy.
This is why I don't believe in her.
I think she had like three instances where she could have
all did.
At least, I think.
I messed up... I messed... I might have messed up his...
Oh, no.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
We saw White Fox.
As long as they don't, they're missing their White Fox.
Okay, never mind.
Now we're missing both healers and they have both healers
right now.
Don't worry.
I'm skating.
I'm skating fast.
Gotta skate.
This guy doesn't die bro.
See, I couldn't see anything.
Oh no.
I'm just gonna stay here.
Okay.
It's fine, I'm a lot.
I mean, it's even now.
I don't think we're up one.
I think we're, oh wait, now we are, yeah.
Oh, unlucky.
I thought that would...
Oh no!
Hey guys!
Who cares?
My life don't matter in a team game.
Oh wow.
Look at that.
Oh wait, Fox is dead.
Move the points.
Move it.
Got it, boss.
We got it.
No, no, what?
Just tap it.
only 60 seconds left this is a team effort did you not hear
what the wait does that block oh that i swear there i swear
to get does that block the tp it's just me i feel like when
i play this game i feel more chill but as soon as i play
overwatch like the demon comes out of me like you guys are
chill people in overwatch everyone's just fucking miserable
that's overwatch yep that sounds like overwatch he's
reforming guys it's like a hit
Okay, right?
There we go.
Don't worry, I'm dancing to you, man!
I'm gonna check out the- they're down three right now.
I dance!
I dance so hard!
No, I don't know about that, though.
Okay, it would...
Okay.
It's alright.
Easy.
I'm coming back.
I'm skiing skate fast.
Yay What are you in particular?
Fuck me, I guess.
Oh, yeah, they like kind of indirectly nerf triple support
quite heavy.
Why is this game so hard?
Is it me since the guy that's 46 and not the 25 10?
Please tell me Might be me low-key.
I'm taking so but there we go he recognizes himself there at
least he knows at least he knows i was just like the guy
that's the 40 46 like is it me guys it's a me while he's
next to the crew
yeah no uh all should they play ultra super strong bro like
it's actually so strong at least he i want Yeah,
self-reflection, yeah.
Can we see how that goes?
Can we get right?
At least he's aware that he is the problem.
All right.
Okay, the White Fox now is doing a lot better.
I'm still dying, but at least they're less stupid than
during defense.
So the nerfs didn't affect that character yet.
No, no, no.
I talk goodbye still.
You still says that character's Thanos.
Yeah.
Probably.
I'll save it.
I won't use it.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
They had more time than us was that.
What do you mean?
They literally pushed 40 minutes.
They don't want those things.
Like, I don't even have more time.
They literally pushed 40 minutes not like, sorry, four
minutes non-stop there, which was crazy.
I hate these walls so fucking much.
Look at that.
Look at them.
Oh my god.
Please don't.
Oh.
Oh, guys, I think they might be ghosts.
Wait.
Oh my god.
TP, TP.
Kill two.
Stay touching.
We have a TP coming.
We have to touch!
I swear to...
Oh, not the moon.
Not the moon.
All right.
They might TP.
Oh, no TP.
All right.
I really need...
I can alter.
Okay.
No.
I'm gonna try and build all right now.
I hope he lets me out first and we don't actually double
support all because that would be such a shame.
See if I can pull one in.
Okay.
Oh, no!
I had no one to heal!
Okay.
Oh, no.
far away.
I keep myself flake, but I don't want to heal except myself.
He actually heals quite a bit more, I think.
Then left quick.
There's an area healing.
What
the fuck is going on?
I can't see anything.
It's just all particles.
We're honestly good for a few players.
everything i just saw a hundred particles on my screen where
what is anything just just say that you'll need a top-notch
team to win this yeah i think that's fine i'm gonna find a
sure like the moon i can't see shit i'm just surprised we
didn't use any of our hopes there there will does so much
damage into uh like squishies but like cannot kill things
literally it was just i don't know it It was just everything
was on my screen.
I just watched my stream sniping.
I'm not streaming.
How did you know I said something?
I'm watching Yogi right now.
Why wouldn't I do this?
Oh my god, she's a fan.
Oh my god.
I'm not a fan.
I just I was like, is that dirty?
That's it.
Lost your Privilege list to speak on my stream.
You've lost your privilege
Privilege is God Because we're chilling I'm not though No,
we are chilling.
We are chilling No more privilege is on the agenda once
again uh like you would i wouldn't do anything to get chill
lobbies like this pair i swear no triple support both teams
are running what they want it from it's basically like a bot
much better oh how is one
that's right no more she didn't have to say that now my
feelings are hurt that's right my fragile ego oh what
the fuck oh that's awkward for art i must have my love just
give me up when i have it i'm doing this my way
you up as much oh that's unlucky i have to die on point i
have to die on point don't don't stagger guys we just gotta
win one fight prove her you can't expect everyone to be a
fat but she didn't have
have to say that that's an inside thought not an outside
thought what are they gonna do what are they gonna do oh
what the fuck shouldn't have done that
all right we use everything
There you go.
All right.
Like, look, I, there's no way you are questioning my
answers.
I used to get paid for this game.
You're telling me that you are losing the game.
Look at that.
I just dropped them to.
I died.
I used to get paid.
Who are you?
I used to get paid in this game.
I love you, bro.
I love you.
Do not listen to her.
I love you, bro.
Wait, has she been shit talking?
Wait, she...
I was like, who is he arguing with?
It was fucking demons?
I was just like...
Like, he's like peeping with the voices.
See?
She...
She was shit talking.
Bro, bro's talking.
Yeah, I was like, who is he beefing with?
I was like, oh, the person I'm muted.
I, too, fight with the demons.
Look.
Look, if she didn't say that, I wouldn't have muted her.
If the mute was right.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
That's right.
That could have been an inside thought.
Oh, another white fox player.
Alright.
Let's go.
the main Elsa okay that's good to know I feel like
everybody's a Elsa main
guys who do you think is going to be announced tomorrow for
my concert
I want to see if you guys can guess it do I have any chill
people on the team me any chillers oh those are some good
guesses those are some really good guesses
I will say all like obviously all my guests are people I've
collabed with I mean that would make sense like they have to
be you know
they're all people I've collabed with there's no like super
surprise guest or something be like where did they come from
room it is people that I've worked with or collab with
let me know from their iron fist plays back and I'll feel
all right I will say someone has guessed tomorrow's
tomorrow's announcement for the guest someone has given the
right guess could be any of them though for tomorrow for
tomorrow's announcement.
I don't even know what time it's going to be announced.
Wow.
I hate that skin so much.
Not bad.
I did not consent.
I don't know.
It's just, you know, you know, they can, there's, you know,
skins that are like Hooner skins, but then they have to have
taste, you know?
This is like, Like they tried too hard.
You know what I'm saying?
Like...
Oh my god, whoop.
That's my bad.
That was my bad.
I...
I should have healed her.
I fucked up.
I should have healed him.
Oh, I thought they would peek that, honestly.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, I hear.
I hear the wringling thing.
Ooh, will our venom be okay?
Yeah, he will.
A little worried about my venom there.
Oh, I hear it.
I'm gonna get...
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Okay, it's fine.
Good thing is okay.
There's just a bit too many things on my screen right now.
Just a little bit.
I will say there is a little bit too much stuff going on
with my screen.
Okay, nice.
Nope.
No TP.
Oh, he's won.
nice to play black cat they're throwing my first time
playing it's a black cat i don't know what she does she
seems i think she's gonna spam me i will say she seems
really bad right now she'll be probably fine holy shit he
got deleted so fast though oh my god
they got deleted so fast
me first me first me first i'll go up front so they know
we oh
oh i thought i said me first but i said it in that's all
right can't believe he didn't have my stream open so he know
i said me first
I can't believe it.
How dare he not know?
I said it very loud in my own stream.
She was farther than...
She TPed!
She cheated!
That doesn't count.
She fucking cheated.
I was up first.
That's why you see more like hulks and thorns because
they're actually not going to get actually like raped.
Well, clearly they're hulk-hulks and then they die.
But I don't know about that one.
Oh my god, this guy has all I swear to God if he's like,
okay, that's good Can I also just all or Emma?
Am I just alt here on this corner?
Okay, I'll just stay here.
I'm doing predictions right now
Yeah Yeah, I was waiting for that alt not I'm not gonna lie.
Okay, nice.
Yay!
Me first?
Me first!
Whoa!
That's it.
Okay, yeah, so let's go.
Okay, I might be able to do it.
Me first!
Okay.
There we go.
See?
We did it!
Hey, listen!
Dance, dance, dance, dance.
Oh.
she is that easy guys the guy literally blocked his
teammates now yeah now she has my stream open
yes i expect them to read my mind you'll need a top-notch
team to win this job i said me first how dare she not know
my signal to her.
Like, excuse me.
Round two.
Alright.
Also, the ice effects look great on stage.
Everyone having a good day today.
I hate it when people just don't know what I'm thinking
about.
I don't know when I want to ult first.
Hattie, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Itachi, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Back shots, thank you for the tier one, so.
Thank you.
It looks like it's not going all right anymore.
Okay.
Um, I think the reason why this is how I'm gonna actually
switch off that button.
Hey.
Okay, it happens.
Maybe I'll trade the zombie.
Killing the concert?
Thank you.
I was very worried about it.
I'm glad it sounded good.
I heard it was pretty good.
Three, two, one.
Yeah, I'm glad it is.
You have to stop them.
You're securing the mission area.
I saw them sign up for you.
Oh, we're running cloak now.
I'm gonna watch basketball.
You know what?
Fuck these guys.
I'm gonna DPS.
All right.
No one of them need heals.
That Groot is so dead.
That's right!
And now I'll give heals.
That's right.
need heals.
I DPS.
Guys, something tells me that...
Yeah.
I think they left the game.
I know who I'm avoiding.
Oh my god, I can't believe I missed that.
Hey, no.
Yeah, I I think, I think, I think he's like, that's it.
Freelo.
I love Freelo.
I've not used this to heal anyone else yet.
I've only flaked myself.
As I should.
I'm a strong, independent Luna.
Oh, oh, I couldn't heal them.
Wait, we have triple 10?
No.
I was...
I woke though!
Oh wait, he's still playing Black Cat?
I'm just chucking in the heels and just hoping it...
I'm just like...
Going Kobe right now.
Look at us, girl!
Look at us!
This is embarrassing.
Alright, maybe I... I might need to... I might need to avoid
like everybody on the enemy team.
I don't think I want any of these people playing with me.
Oh my god, that black cat was so bad.
I missed five shots, but like...
He also missed five shots.
Don't worry, fuck it.
PPS time for me.
Yeah, I might have to avoid that entire team.
Like, I really don't want to have any of them on my team.
We dance!
And then I leave.
Oh shit!
Ooh!
Wait.
Oh, it's just me.
Alright.
Oh, never mind.
We might have been a little too cocky.
Just a little bit.
Just a little bit too cocky.
Okay, he doesn't know.
down to 30 seconds all right we're ready the ult jump to
jump to the fancy oh
why'd you put the portal in the air lucky we might have been
a little too cocky all right no more damage
oh shit i didn't realize sorry that was my bad i didn't
realize the back line was going through some stuff
all right throwing over throwing over now we actually gaming
now please don't mind the the whiff ice but starting now
okay that's good
oh that's not good oh that's not good oh that's not good
okay starting now starting now guys starting now look see if
i told you starting now look i gave my dps the snowflake all
right team press w here because they have nothing no one
stands between me and my in the back.
Starting now.
Alright, see where I am?
Okay, do you want to load your...
Oh.
I was worried.
Oh, no.
That's not good.
Alright.
See, I told you.
Starting now.
There you go.
Oh my god, it's my cloak okay.
so healthy.
Oh, she is.
She was so healthy, though.
She was so healthy.
Nice.
Yo, Gigi is.
Yay.
She might have hated me.
I might have.
She might have actually hated me.
I might have let her die when she should have died.
But hey, I won.
We still win.
Just wanted to make it a little bit more exciting for her.
We gotta get rid of.
The black cat.
The.
Oh, definitely the heal pool.
Definitely the heal pool.
No, we gotta.
Yeah, no.
We gotta get this guy out of here.
And then.
There we go.
I diffed your heals.
loser you heal bot loser
damn that is true he is he did heal bot how do you have zero
final hits on deadpool
i don't blame her like if anything you should be frat you
have a gun if it how are you not your guns to shoot.
How is there zero?
How is there zero final hits?
See, here's a pro tip.
Apparently, you're...
I mean, it's sort of the same for, like, for rivals right
now.
You have to...
I mean, same for, like, all Elo.
What the fuck?
Why is Super Gilma is here?
Super Gilma is the oldest animal's player.
Oh, my God.
He is?
you think you want to be today guys we have a pro player on
our team this game is like only a year old they're saying
like he's like a january you're like it's like he's saying
like he hasn't been here for 20 years no it's not been three
months since death this game is only one years old i swear
the guy was like wait oh my god no don't tell me like yeah
they're talking about him like he died or some like he went
on a pilgrimage 10 20 years ago and then he came back the
ancient one half returned Anyways, are you gonna, are you
gonna play like Iron Fist or something?
Oh, I'm just playing Magneto.
Alright.
I picked Cloak hoping that no one will ban Cloak.
Ban my Mag, I guess, huh?
Guys, also guys, I might actually finally play Tomodachi
live because I have an idea.
I finally have figured out an idea for the island.
The only reason why I was like struggling with deciding what
to do with the island.
is uh what is this winter soldier got like apparently uh
what's that i just didn't know um oh he got reworked you
know i just didn't know what to do but i figured it out and
it was like the million dollar idea threshold the island is
just all dokeys but like i would be like i wouldn't give
them any different name they'll just be called dokeys
because you could have each me each me can be can share the
same name so it'll be a surprise always to figure out which
dokey they're talking about it will be like dope kitty or a
dokey bug it'll just be like dokey dokey dokey dokey dokey
dokey the actual dokey verse i'll create the dokey verse And
I'll have one, one dad and one dragon.
Cooler, don't you not that dorky, that dorky.
That's fair, yeah.
He's lucky.
I like it when I shoot something and I die.
That's fair.
So why are you playing right now?
Oh, I need a drag here.
He cannot say that.
Let the record show.
That he wanted to be here.
There was no dragging.
Oh yeah, you know they got CC protection now, right?
CC does not work.
It does not work.
Oh yeah, I mean.
Because.
All right.
Side up.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What on spider?
What?
There was no.
No dragging here.
That's right.
Who could it be?
Wait, he's playing with someone guys.
Who could who could he be playing with?
We'll never know We'll never know
What the fuck?
You like died so fast.
Oh, they got tetanon on the end of the team, bro.
This is the wins.
Third group player, I get them on bottom of the team.
It's all fine.
All right.
I don't know.
Something I don't miss is just push that.
My push thought barely works.
Okay.
I said that as an honorary dragon, I am playing with you.
Yeah.
What the fuck is jerky?
Oh shit, goodbye!
That might be a really shitty ult.
But I did not want to go there.
I did not want to get...
Okay.
Oh shit, we're fucked.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Our Loki, I think.
I didn't even hear what he said.
What the fuck did he say?
Oh, they're all fucking.
I don't have them anymore now.
He's like joking, bird.
And it was just all words.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what you want from me you got asked to man if
only oh my god if only our Loki did something die on point
die point die point oh my bro we said die on point not me
Oh, oh, that's unlucky.
No, look here, Venom just sold us.
You guys stat saved and didn't die on me.
Alright, there we go.
That's fine, just keep healing!
Alright, it's fine, it's fine, I'm healing.
It's all right, it's fine, I'm healing.
All right.
Oh, they have.
Oh, my God.
I can't do anything.
I'm not fast enough.
It's okay.
Our Loki is still alive.
He has no one to copy.
Play your life, bro.
Oh.
You would have lived that.
Why did you go on there?
Oh.
Oh, that's pretty cool.
Oh, Phoenix is bad.
Oh, that's fine.
Yeah, he's living.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's go
Here I am here I am here I am here I am this is your moment
to shine Oh my god there you go It's like Loki here I am if
that's why and then let's chill here we go
i looked at him i see why you hate this game by the way we
looked at each other yeah i love that oh i someone and
someone counterplays by just healing someone there you go
you're like the next triadic okay okay all right it's fine
you guys all you guys all just chill in my little bubble it
is much more relaxing to all they went they went thing now I
will say it's definitely much more relaxing to play club
because I don't have the a Oh Oh Oh, no, no, no I would have
been at the reman all and I got stunned Fuck my life, bro.
We have All right, here I am Here I am Oh, fuck!
No, never mind.
No more here.
We are.
Yeah, the thing got us both, by the way.
Oh, it's unlucky.
They have no supports, you have no supports, so...
Oh, no.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, one!
That's unlucky.
We can't, like, we can't keep letting them cap like this,
guys, if we start losing, like, There I go.
I have a hat fade.
I had to use it for it Their own solo thing.
Yeah, they were solo thing thing we easily just this guy's
terrible too
It's all right Oh
Oh, that's good.
That's huge.
Oh, yeah, y'all got to start playing no life on tank.
I'm just going to do that.
All right.
They have.
Oh, they're going to let you roll in a second.
All right.
Definitely have stranger They don't have a combo Oh, that's
unlucky
Please do I not, I killed on my sword I killed the enemy Oh
my god I'm having a bird Alright
Goodbye everybody Unless Oh
Unless that solo up was not worth it.
Let's go.
Who would have done?
I live.
That's right.
You'll need a top notch team to win this one.
They thought they got me.
There's no way we're playing.
I'm playing the games with Gokie, Bird, and Gomez at the
same time.
That's me.
You're getting Bill Blowjack claimed that sometimes.
Who said that?
I wasn't paying attention.
Dude, I don't know who anybody is.
Oh my god, we're with Gokie Bird?
Back in like season four.
Where is she?
It could be any one of them.
It could be Icy Lava Man.
Bill B.J.
Clint.
Super Gomez, Nodask, or Adam.
It could be any one of them.
Doki could be any one of these people.
There's no way it's Doki, man.
Who would name?
Why would they name them?
After themselves.
Yeah, Doki would never call herself Doki, man.
I thought it would be really funny if I just put the word DJ
as his middle name.
Honestly?
It could be you.
It could be me.
It could even be.
My other all to account is this.
altar mate is it all that's my other that's my first altar
count in chat what's your main what's your main uh mori hui
all right i don't remember mori i know that way wait i don't
know i'm looking blushing right now screwball i'm not gonna
forget from the people no wait wait is this a good
you can you can take that as the way you want oh no more no
more players and the more players it's never a good thing
okay no i'm like i'm a nice player though uh really good
gonna be up here i was talking about how they stand now i
was really let's go they're just giving us space for free
like oh never mind no reason reason wait wait wait wait when
you slam in i'm gonna have to backline that's gonna say wow
oh whoa that's awkward yeah five whoa what let's just leave
yo i'm gonna back up bro oh my god we live oh my god we we
live
here one two one two one this might be oh i don't even know
if i shield that oh i can end out all this after what no no
what all right
oh you guys are i was looking at crazy It's fine!
It's still winnable!
My ult!
Look at that!
I did!
My ult!
I didn't fuck it up!
What the fuck?
Oh shit!
Alright, it's a bit unfortunate that we did up though.
I mean, I don't see anyone using it like a shield, like they
should.
Bro, this is Doki Bird's home.
We're kind of insulting her right now.
No, no, I heard, I swear to God I heard someone juggle.
What?
No, wait, I see lava man, bro.
What did they say?
What did he say about me?
I wasn't paying attention.
i can make an xbox account and so that's what i named it and
oh but you didn't have it you didn't have a randomly
generated xbox man i did oh one that mine was like woody
carrot or something and then i did mine was unread brush six
five what is going on i only know one kid who kept their
actual xbox all right i shall now leave now i can handle
them see how that's unlucky that's unlucky i'm gonna stumble
over these That is so unlucky for me.
Wait, look, I'm on.
Yeah, but defending me for what?
I...
I came out.
What did it...
Like defending me from what?
I even registered someone said something about me.
You know you're crap.
I don't know.
I don't know how to play Smash Man.
Gang, I don't know how to deal with this guy right here.
Yeah, it's all mumbling.
I will say...
You're so right.
No one's there to capitalize bro, I'm sorry.
That was an aura ult.
Oh,
we couldn't kite it.
Oh, that's fine, they use guilds.
We will have both support ults coming.
I'm... me first.
Yo, no dad.
Do you think you just like play your life on behind or
behind?
If you die, then I support you get walked on.
And that's like, that's a really bad thing.
All right, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I think you just stunned a little.
I'm not going to lie, but I don't know.
Yeah.
Let's go.
I get one, I get one.
I get one.
Should that stop at all?
Oh, my God.
Hey, let's still go.
That's right.
Close one, close one, close one.
Can I get back one?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, we're fine.
We're fine.
Like, I can't hear what he's saying.
He's...
Hello,
there is a name we're up top.
I hope that they 1v1.
And more and more we'll talk.
Ah, I'm next to him.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
I thought he was behind me to copy.
I guess not.
That was my bad.
I guess I should have.
Alright, let's just regroup.
I thought Loki was behind me.
I would have fucking...
Turn around and heal them
Coming over I forced out the enemy.
Yeah, he can't fight him if you want to get on
Come on point Oh my god Oh no, oh no Kill the magic, please
kill the magic kill the magic kill the magic I just took a
magic please I'm in my circle though I'm in my oh no I
wasn't sure we get this kill Loki no go miss that portal he
didn't portal my dude I did it portal he did
Oh, no.
We just didn't kill the magic of Loki.
And no dash.
Sorry, no dash.
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I didn't realize our Loki was getting dope so much.
If I realized I would have turned around and...
Like, I was like, Loki, I'm right in front of you.
You can copy me.
But then he didn't copy.
So I was like, okay.
He didn't copy me.
So I don't know if he was getting dope So he couldn't copy
me But I looked back and he was fine when I looked back
Wasn't my fault that when I didn't look back When I looked
forward he was dead
I have to win on cloak Oh no I don't I want to relax now I'm
going to finish this match
be done as i should i guess i could have peeled him more but
also like i didn't want to
i should have but you know how sometimes you just don't want
to
really that's fine
Doesn't it suck when your support player when your support
duo just doesn't feel like healing you couldn't be me All
right, what time is how long I've been streaming for seven
hours.
Whoa
The healer attacks.
Yeah, see this is why I pick look so no my team doesn't ban
cloak Pick your hero or villain.
I'm not judging Oh, I'm ready
All right, I still can't believe I, like, I
copyright-striked myself for the girlfriend cover.
It's not, the song's still not backed up yet.
Like, it worked.
It worked because the...
Um...
Because, like, the fake cover got taken down.
But then they were like oh there was another cover.
There was another cover So we got to take this one down, but
the other cover was my cover No, we haven't heard anything
back dude the other cover was my cover
Yeah, they shot the clone in the original I went the wrong
way I got so confused I got really, really confused where
people were going.
People still even play Gambit?
Oh, I should heal.
That's a healer.
I should really start healing.
Whoa!
Alright, nice, we got it.
Yeah, you do not want to hear your healer say I should heal.
might not be very ideal.
Woo!
That's right, didn't grab me!
Oh my.
Don't worry, simple geometry.
Fine over there.
Suck.
Thing is, I don't even know if like Gambit is still good
this meta.
I feel like this, I have no idea.
what is good i've been playing for like how many hours now
on on rivals and i i can't tell it feels like a free-for-all
i can't tell what's good or not
whoo who's gambiting oh oh yeah i'm not using oh i'm not
I have up for next fight.
I didn't want to use it because I was just like, ooh.
Oh, that means I'm about to play Loki then.
He's still busted?
Okay.
I'll go Loki, Loki then.
I can use this aggressively, honestly.
And I could have went deeper, but I got really scared.
Oh, uh, fucking cool.
Oh, it's all right, I guess.
Oh, man.
Missed.
All right.
Suck.
Oh, come on.
Come on!
Why are they all...
Why do they all want to kill me?
I literally had two tanks run at me.
What do you want?
all right so gambit is still good i hope i hope as like the
not if i am doing the rival tournament i hope that as the
not captain i will not be oh my god knowing my competitive
side i'll still be trying to i
feel like knowing my competitive side i'll still try to like
figure out bads and stuff.
Just knowing me.
I'm trying my best.
I'm trying.
Oh.
Wait, they already got the point.
I didn't realize they capped the point.
I'm just gonna hope.
Oh, that's not good.
That's not good.
Oh, no.
Oh,
no, we lost!
Wait, unless...
That's fine.
Oh my god, the gambit...
Gambit never falls.
It worked!
Unless...
Alright, now I can play low-key.
It was always winnable.
It's a VTuber rivals tournament.
Round two of the Iron Mouth Sea Dog one.
good round team.
Mac, think about Twitch Prime thinking, thank you.
He asked me if I want to join and I said, I want to do it if
I'm not captain.
Because I didn't want to be captain again.
Um...
But I feel like even though I'm even if I'm like on a team
and I'm not captain, I feel like I would still have to
figure out bad and just... I feel like I still would have to
IGL.
I feel like I I still might be put unless like There's
someone around my level That's also on my team But I don't
know If there's someone around my level That's also on my
team Or better than me Then I'll let them IGL And I'll just
exist Or let them figure out the band system
Because bands were the hardest Because it's like literally
rock paper scissors and I'm too tired.
You know?
I'm tired.
It's literally just...
It's like rock paper scissors.
Yeah, they never fall.
Oh my god.
I just got deleted.
I couldn't even press shift.
That was crazy.
I was about to press shift and then it i was just i'm just
dead
oh it's because they have squirrel girl okay that makes
sense i was gonna say how the fuck did i get deleted so fast
i'm just gonna use this since i'm solo healing right now
it's just way too much damage
all right there you go all right damage never fell
Holy shit that was scary Good thing I had cleanse I almost
forgot how to cleanse I was just like Which button?
It's been so long It's been so long
Hey everyone play up I'm on a hold Alright Breathe
I'm just gonna chill over there.
I don't want to get hit
Nice Oh, oh doesn't matter.
Oh, they don't stand in my in Vaughn area
Oh somebody I'm right here with healing magic
Time to vanish can't help you that much gambit.
Oh gambit.
Oh Oh gambit.
Don't worry.
I'm literally get better i'm alive oh my god i'm oh not him
though not him no more uh i should i should have went back
to my team i i was alive and here we go again the more the
merrier it's all right oh they're all dead it's no longer
okay i'm everywhere it's all right i'm invisible
we're okay now i'm gonna press my ultimate first all right
yes it's time All right, you guys ready?
Gambit never falls!
They have no David, no more.
I don't think I need to use all of here.
Yeah.
That's right.
I controlled myself.
First a gambit.
What a fucking nerd
All right I haven't played since this character came out
It's just it's never false There's my gambit Wait copy
mirror I mean we need it now Go go go go go go go go Gabbit
never false Oh shit Gabbit never falls Hey guys?
There we go.
Gambit never folds!
He doesn't do laundry.
This is bad though.
Oh never mind it's no longer bad.
It's alright.
Gambit never folds.
We did it.
That sucks.
It must be sucked to be married.
I guess he must be like, you know, he's like a...
You can say he's a house husband, but he just doesn't do
laundry.
I feel like he'd be a good cook.
He's gotta be a good cook.
He seems like a stay-at-home dad.
Yeah?
I would say so.
Isn't he...
What are they calling it?
uh he he yeah Cajun?
Oh Cajun, yeah never mind Cajun
I would say like if he's Cajun he should be like really
really good at cooking just as their food is really good
he just doesn't do laundry
I'm a never fools I'm banning Gambit.
We're never letting him out.
cannot, I can't with Gambit.
Not again.
I mean, as long as I don't have to play Gambit, I'm fine.
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know if I hate, which character I hate more to play.
I think Loki, actually.
I might hate Loki more than Gambit.
Only because, like, I'm so tired right now to think with
clones.
Like, right now.
Right now, I'm a little too tired to play with clones right
now.
I don't hate Loki.
I just...
I'm tired of clones.
I'm tired of placing clones.
Because you gotta be smart with it, and I was not.
I don't know if you saw how I was placing clones, just
chucking it off cooldown because I was not thinking I was
just like I was like let me throw this clone right in front
of me into the enemy lines you're right you know it's rocket
time I deserve rocket time you're so right I got treat
myself.
I'm going to treat myself to some rocket.
If we load in.
Who is warrior waiting on?
Oh, Trello.
Yeah, Trello seems stuck.
um, bum, bum,
bum, bum, bum, bum.
Any day now?
No.
Rocking.
is now freed he's free into the world
oh well guess it got guess it got cancelled he never showed
up he never showed up my life away Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum.
At least we're back on the screen that mad- You know what?
I think it's time.
And the world said no.
The world was not ready.
The world...
It is not time.
Thank you, world.
I don't play Rocket.
And I'm going to go pee.
I'll be right back.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
What's going on, team?
Oh my god, it's Gomez.
Oh my god, they keep my shorts.
Oh my god.
On a good day today.
Yes, no.
Good talk.
Good talk, y'all.
I'm back.
I knew I had so much time.
There's three bands, each team.
We were going to have so much time.
I was not worried at all.
Oh, double Elsa.
Let's go.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
shit.
All right, running white.
Are we Help Master?
We just saved the...
Okay, we're attack.
Oh, we should just tell us this.
Attack or defense here.
Never mind, one defense.
I just assumed, like, stop Spotter Zero from reaching the
web.
Oh, we're stopping.
Okay, it said help.
help with defense okay i would assume uh i thought the big
spider over there was a good spider all right i used to put
the res i don't remember how is my hero thing i shouldn't
hear i actually don't remember no
already how did you get hurt doing my best I'm chucking
chucking the balls not more I can do other than chucking the
balls yeah all right that'll be fine holy shit she was not
okay she was okay you're not gonna a five-mile rise.
It's so...
Oh, that was a good pull.
That was actually a really good pull.
It's okay.
If he dies, watch this.
Four and again!
Alright.
That's right.
And then if he dies again, then unlucky.
That's on them.
Alright.
Ooh.
Wait, our Bucky is pretty good.
Let's see who's up there.
What did he grab?
Oh, rogue.
Yeah, I have another boy in again soon.
Uhhhh...
No way he'll know.
Now our Bucky has really good hooks.
They're so relaxing.
It's great because they're not diving me.
It's always nice.
Okay, all here.
This is real firepower.
He's died.
Wait, he's dead.
Wait a minute.
It's okay.
We're jumping.
I'm backing up.
Ooh, that's a lot of us.
What you gotta do now?
Exactly!
Nothing!
Alright.
No one will know the res is back here.
Do you think he knows?
I think he knew.
Sorry, I'm still alive, though.
Look at me go.
I'm surviving.
I feel like when you're playing Rocket, it's a whole
different game.
It's really an AFK, like a cookie clicker.
I think he might I think he might be dead
I did the best I could Goodbye Goodbye Bucky
Oh no Okay we have portal, we have portal We have portal,
it's winnable Okay I'll go in Throw the all out And then
Chuck the res here?
And then...
Look at that.
Look at that play.
Look at that multitask.
I'm multitasking.
Now our bucky was really good.
That's a flarking job.
That's me.
Again.
things up including which side so easy you'll need a
top-notch team to win this one boy you calling a raccoon and
why or new york city or new york engine think about twitch
prime thank you thank you i do think when you're playing
rocket you're not even playing the game itself okay like i
could just jam out to some to some tracks here billy bays on
our team
I could literally be watching Cocoa Mellon on the second
screen.
That I'd still be alive.
I haven't seen that name since the commercials.
Oh my lord.
I would if I...
I would if I'm not scared of Cocoa Mellon copyright striking
me.
I prove it.
I would.
I would put Cocoa Mellon on the side of the screen.
And then we...
To be honest, the average rocket player Probably watch Coco
Melon You're not even playing the same game I don't know,
you got reincarnated Some Marvel Rivals What a fate worse
than death
Alright, just gotta be sure there's no Spider-Man Oh I'm
actually so slow I actually tried recalling Like Tracer I've
been playing too much Overwatch That's a little unfortunate.
It's alright.
We have Res.
On point.
Oh, but don't die twice.
Who else died?
Oh, Bailey Mays died.
I'm solo healing, so be careful, guys.
Nothing I can do right now.
I'm just chucking my nades.
Okay.
My little girl.
heal pellets oh nice we got kill look at that now we got
another kill so easy look at that easiest game of my life oh
fuck what the fuck why me I was the only one there oh my god
I see him
That's right, get out of here.
I don't think he got anyone.
Alright, I'll stay here.
Alright, do your thing, guys.
Oh, goodbye.
This guy just hates me.
I don't know.
He really wants to kill me.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
My alt got solo ulced, and then I got chased by Mr.
Fantastic.
You know why.
Why did I nerf the wall run?
I don't...
The nerf wall run...
Okay, it's not noticeable, but also because...
Okay, it is noticeable, but also because I was at the
fucking...
Yeah.
The map literally has no walls to run in.
I did pick Rocket.
I mean, Rocket is alright to play on this map.
I'm surprised we haven't got the other Spider-Man map yet.
Honestly.
Oh, wait.
I think it's time.
I think I do one more game.
I'm tired.
I'm getting tired now.
I'll do one more game There you go Yeah Oh wait has to be
here maybe All right Ooh
Perfect first try getting the angle right for that too I'm
just a professional
Yeah, I'll say LG.
Tired now.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
LG.
It was surprising.
More people recognized me in Rivals than Overwatch.
I think almost every other game, they're like, Donkey Bird.
Who am I going to vanish from this match?
While in the past, more people used to recognize me in
Overwatch compared to the Rivals, but now it's the opposite
now.
Ah!
Alright.
Let's run this.
Even, guys, even if we lose, it will still be LG.
Let me let you guys know right now.
Even if we lose, it will still be LG.
BLG.
Wait, how's that name allowed?
Mr. Hemeroids.
Because there's a one.
Hemeroids.
Wow.
Yeah, I'm tired.
Now I'm actually E.B.
I fixed my sleep schedule.
Mr. Hemeroids.
I fixed my sleep schedule today.
I actually did.
I went to bed around 10.
And then woke up at like 8?
I woke up at 9, I think.
I should sleep at 10.
I think no I went to bed 11 And I woke up at 9 So I finally
fixed it Oh What do I want to play?
Mantis Wait actually I could do ultra.
Oh ultra's bad.
Oh, I was expecting that response.
I'm not gonna lie Oh, okay Why bad my mag?
We ended on triple support.
Let's fucking go.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Yay.
We ended the most marble rivals of all rivals.
I'm no more no more.
But if we gotta be fighting this fight, at least we get to
do it side by side.
The battle starts in five, four, three, Alright.
Where the fuck is he?
Ah.
Oh.
That's fine.
I knew he was gonna win that.
With the damage boost too.
Let's go.
That's right!
Triple support!
The thing is they have to go triple support.
Let's see if any of them have egos.
Let's see.
Oh fuck, okay, we might have pushed a little too hard.
We might have...
Whoopsie!
Oops.
Oopsie.
We got a little too confident.
Oh, no, you so did.
I hear somebody.
Oh, my God.
My bad.
That wall looked really sleepy.
Oh, I love you.
I knew I would have.
The only issue right now.
Oh, me dead.
There we go.
He's so low, though.
Are you serious?
Really?
Where did he come from?
Oh, my God.
I didn't even see that.
Wait, are we fighting that?
Oh, nice.
Oh, we have Fox.
Oh my god, this guy really wants to win.
I am ready to put on a show.
Gambit, gambit, gambit, gambit, gambit, gambit.
How do you get there?
No more in height, no more in height, no more in height.
BP is gonna be behind.
Why me?
He literally...
He literally just looked at me!
AJ!
Why?
I'm so...
I'm DP!
Okay.
Oh my god, he's dead.
Where is he?
Oh my god, he's so fast!
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Where is things?
Oh, he definitely is close to it.
He's so low.
Come on.
Get him in the back.
Get him the one.
There we go.
Good point.
Oh my god, finally, I hit a headshot, too.
I got three on me, three on me.
Oh,
but I hope he's okay.
He was not okay.
Guys, I hit the sleep, though.
Oh my god, I hit another sleep.
Oh, no, not...
Oh, fucking course.
Oh, wait, he got off of...
Pass.
You know what?
I'm happy with that.
I cannot be bothered to aim at Panther right now.
I can't be bothered.
I'm like, good.
I fucking knew it.
Every time.
I had a feeling, too.
I felt it.
I was like, the stranger's right behind me.
He's about to do it, isn't he?
I mean, we have Fox up.
I might actually be tempted.
I'm tempted to just go shark, actually.
I don't think we need.
All right.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he's so low.
Really?
That one there, that one there, that one there.
Oh my god.
Nice.
He's sleeping, he's sleeping, he's so tired.
It might be Fox time!
Fox time!
Fox, um...
Okay.
We're gonna have no more, no more, no more, no more.
No TP, TP.
Never love, never love.
Oh no, we don't have Fox up.
We don't have Fox up right now.
Strange killable, strange killable.
Lunar healing comes on.
Kill the road!
We don't need it.
Oh my god, our fox died.
Please,
he's so low.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck was our fox all?
In the entire time this person has been holding it
Okay Thanks how long I'm gone Okay Oh shit.
Oh, I'm okay I'm okay
This guy is an actual hater.
This guy...
Why was he there?
Oh, why?
That's the guy.
It's just me.
It was just me.
Oh, my God.
He used the fox up.
He actually used it.
I could tell.
Oh.
again again we just lose because i die first no i'm our only
damage i don't think anybody's tpa i have some score
okay we're portaling we're portaling
please i really oh my god it's all up that didn't matter
oh my god i got it we got it
I can't see oh I got him
It's like I can't see never mind
Run again run again bit Okay, you got I can change I can
change go change change change change change change change
change change You fucker It's a goddamn name Please do not
drag out Gamadol next time.
Just pop in Mira.
You guys made it No
He wants me so bad
No, who cares his old does more damage The whole point of
Gamadol is more damage and movement and heals everything
okay I don't even know I want to stay the mantis okay might
be tempted to go a shark fuck it let's go this might be a I
just feel like I'm he has him hammeroids Please be kind.
Is this the support role?
Yes, oh, you're all your hammeroids.
Never mind.
I'm sorry
Please be kind stop I can't sit down for luck.
That's crazy.
He uses very limit time to to play rivals That's insane
That's insane.
Oh
He's like, I don't have much time, but I shall use it.
Jesus Christ.
Nah, he's dead.
Nah, he's very dead.
Oh, nice.
Pierce Heals.
Alright, Pierce Heals.
I just have to stay in the backline and just do this all the
time.
attack.
Never mind.
What?
What was my HP?
That's crazy.
I did not think you would do that much damage that quickly.
Like, I didn't even have time to, like, register anything.
I don't think I might I'm gonna swap.
I'm just gonna go Mantis.
Evil is a rejection of life.
Thus, I am a guardian against evil.
I don't think it's worth playing.
I think we need the extra damage boost.
Honestly.
I see...
Holy shit, what happened?
What the fuck happened?
Oh, that's unlucky.
you oh we're gonna get on point we'll try oh fuck where is
that heading over
okay nice i'm
okay you're getting rolled boys all right I do have a...
Do we make it in?
We don't.
We don't make it in.
Nope.
I'm gonna...
Oh my god, I didn't...
That, like, scared me so much that I wasn't able to...
It's just strange.
There you go.
Oh my god, there's nothing I could do.
There was nothing I could do.
There was actually nothing I could do.
He has, he has, you know the worst part?
He has strange old, I can tell.
That's the worst part.
Oh,
he has, I have the damage.
I can't use heals right now.
He's so low?
Oh, he still has...
He's one.
It's a goddamn stupid name, or...
No saps, no saps, no saps.
All right, I'm just gonna...
I hear him.
Oh, there he is.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Now it's just me though.
No!
I couldn't get out.
Both our supports.
Both our supports chase the Namor.
And...
Why did both our supports chase Namor?
We had Namor.
We have Cloak though.
Hey, Coco, back in the area.
That's crazy.
I don't know, man.
Come here, come here, come here, come here.
Can that go on point?
You're not a gambit all the way.
We're going to surrender.
All right.
There we go.
All right, he's going to gambit all here.
He's got a stranger.
He's going to be helpful.
holy i'm just i'm trying my best
we are very aggressive oh we are very i don't think he can
oh he can
there he is there it is oh nice man nice
why is there a thing for him with the oh my god he died with
the gambit up We got it It's fine.
We just sold by this universe a better place.
Wait, actually Okay, this is what we do.
This is what we do This last fight, so I have to chuck this
out for them Don't worry don't worry.
Don't worry.
This there is a plan with this because Look yep, yep, he
might be dead.
He might be dead, but look at this He's back He's back.
Oh, and then everybody said everybody said
Well, there was a plan I think a second DPS here would be
kind of nice Maybe a crazy idea.
Oh, that's crazy.
He is too bad.
We have a strange.
I'm not a lie
Yeah, but we lose rogue then we lose a ton of damage so you
choose oh there we go that works all right back to mantis
someone get gambit go back all right here we go let's go
all right they got a they better let me heal most of the we
have two main healers we have to play you gotta let me do
majority of the healing to be fair two of our supports
decided to chase after name or and then died to it and there
are cloak instead of you know crazy you saw our cloak our
gambit died to name our old our cloak was low low he faded
he faded and And then faded as of Neymar instead of fading
it to come back to me, which was crazy because
he actually, he could have lived.
He could have lived if he faded towards me instead.
Thanks.
Push him out of real wish.
Push him out of his image.
Push him tired, boys.
Good.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Under reload.
This is bad.
Holy shit.
They're gonna have some portals before us though, that's the
thing.
Should be 5.
The only scary part.
This cop is so much stronger than without map this.
There we go.
That was a good one.
here's someone
what how did i get deleted
i mean i literally was with my team i literally was i don't
think i could have outplayed that i was literally with my
team.
Yeah, I was like, how do I play something when I'm playing
next to my team?
I guess I could have died higher.
Hear him.
Oh, wow, he jumped over it.
Oh, he's won.
Okay.
Got it.
No more on right, no more on right, okay.
All right.
He's one.
Oh, he was so low.
We have our cloak.
I'm letting our cloak heal.
There you go.
Holy shit.
I'm gonna train, I'm gonna train, I'm gonna train.
I'm just gonna stay here.
Stop.
Oh, I need to.
reload okay nice yeah triple support yeah oh my god didn't
realize how strong the black panther is now that fucking uh
i literally was just next to my support and then i was just
gone like i just
i told you to not die and i'm just like what can i do what
can i he i was next to my team what you want me to do wait
if we win the next one okay if we win the next one i'll be
celestial
guys unless LG Next game LG Guys, but Guys, imagine me
Ranking up both accounts Chat Both accounts Guys, imagine
that You can eat After My tree all right okay wait until he
cues wait until he cues wait until we get into the game wait
until we get in the game
Okay, wait until the game ends.
Wait until the game ends.
Don't worry.
Alright.
That's the last game.
We gotta go back to the classic.
To our roots.
He doesn't know.
Back to where it all began.
Bum-bub-bub-bub.
Okay.
Only if we win.
These games have been pretty easy.
Not gonna lie.
Only if we win.
Rankins this?
Um, Celestial.
I'm GM1 right now, but Celestial.
Celestial.
We got GM4 on Overwatch, and then if we're lucky, if we're
lucky, we're going to have, uh, well, yeah, so let's do heal
here, too.
Um, hello team.
Um,
sorry, bad gambit, that's good.
I really don't want to deal with gambit right now for my
actual LG.
my real LG
all right here we go you'll need a top-notch team to win
this one all right what do I want to play I want to play
rocket I want to play cloak I'll do rocket put a team up all
right let's go
all right LG for real and that's the walk dad
LG for real And then tomorrow We'll have Well two streams
tomorrow Oh one is members I know I said We'll let you
decide I feel like we've already sort of figured out What
next week's schedule is going to be like How long guys Oh
wait How long is mouse How long to beat mouse PI 12 to 20
hours Okay so that would take like two to three streams So
we might do a Prague mod stream all right how about figure
out stream for next next week because I think next week next
week stream is sort of sort of semi set but like with like
games we need to finish so we might have to finish our we
might have to finish the mouse game and then and then also
pragmata that's right didn't grip me what What was that?
Oh, it was...
It was just them wanting to...
What the fuck?
That's bullshit!
I hear someone behind me.
Alright.
Oh, thank god they have a black cat.
Wait, I have an idea.
an idea he's fighting
i jk the jk i jk the jk i thought he wouldn't notice i
thought he wouldn't notice There was so much stuff going on!
How did he know?
Look, I JK the JK.
Holy shit.
Oh my, it's fine.
We have Rose now.
How was I supposed to know?
I should have made it, so...
I should have said it.
when the fight was getting more intense, you know?
When, like, there were so many notifications going on, and
then he wouldn't have noticed it.
It's okay, I still have the end of the game.
I could just be here.
I could be a little street rat.
Is it?
Oh, that's very unlucky for me.
Unless!
It's okay.
Okay, I didn't realize.
Okay, um Let's get right here Oh, come on
Okay, no, I won't be fancy with the res anymore Okay, we've
got the res guys, we've got it I thought it was so clever I
thought I was so clever with my res It only took three tries
And then my res couldn't even be used Anyway I'll put this
out just in case this guy dies Oh he's fine
It's okay Fourth time's the charm as they like to say
Oh Fourth time I'm the child.
It's okay.
I have risk.
Down put.
Do not die on put.
Do not.
Okay.
It's okay.
Captain, our hero.
Oh, hey.
What are you doing here?
Oh.
Whoa.
Stay in the box.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not gonna make it easy.
But...
It's okay.
We got three minutes.
What could go wrong?
She says.
Guys, what could go wrong?
Yay!
He has us.
It's alright!
Oh no, now they know our res is here.
Unless...
It's alright.
See, everything is fine.
What the fuck?
I feel like that Venom is just playing KDA.
This Venom is not doing shit.
Alright, I do have a...
Oruto.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Do I
think I can do it?
Okay, but what?
I don't think we can win this.
Yeah, not anymore.
I mean, that's good.
They wasted up.
They wasted two ups, guys.
I held it for a reason.
Oh, wait.
We have black cat?
I did not even notice that.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I don't know why I thought Alright I mean, that's fine Our
all is, like, back here That's good They wasted Invisal,
guys Invisal for Rock it all I think that's a good
equivalent exchange If you think about it I'll catch you up
Oh, God.
How?
What the fuck?
How did it do that much damage?
That's crazy.
Alright, right after that, we have...
Don't worry.
The res is here.
I'll just wait here.
I'm shooting?
I gotta be in the in this.
Oh, please.
I just got here.
Please.
Oh!
Hey!
My death meant something.
Yay!
My death.
My death wasn't meaningless.
Thank God.
it's all right guys my death helped the team
all right
uh not only is it gm it's uh gm4
I feel like that venom's just gonna kill my wrist so I'm
just gonna play I just put it here who
are you
Now he looks crazy.
Now he looks fucking crazy.
You'd be like, who the...
You'd be like, what?
I hope he's healing me.
Now he's being like, wow, this guy just fucking said this
random person wouldn't...
I would buy you food.
Okay, nice.
I will take that.
Oh, please.
He's just beating me up, guys.
There we go.
We live.
We fucking, surprisingly, we live.
Fight back, don't you?
What can I do?
I'm just a little guy.
I literally need a booster seat.
Alright.
Okay.
Don't worry, everything is okay.
We just keep chucking this.
Oh my god, everybody is so low.
Oh my, it's okay.
I still have I still have res
Yes, both my all's gone Just like that It's gone and it's
gone.
Well, we have boxed up I have interest to play yeah, we're
putting a mouse bi like literally Tomorrow
You think they'll be okay?
You won't know.
I'm just gonna be here.
Catch the bullet.
I'm being helpful, guys.
I'm being so helpful.
I am participating in this game.
Is this the winner's POV?
I told you, playing Rocket is just playing...
Is this big Rocket gameplay?
Just catch it.
I technically don't have to exist as a person.
Just gotta catch it.
Just catch it.
Alright.
Okay.
Please leave me alone.
Look, he left me alone.
Look at that.
See, that's all I have to say.
Please leave me alone.
I think it's almost time.
Yeah, and you just gotta ask nicely.
What the fuck?
Where is that portal?
I'm trying.
there's a fantastic now oh please i'm trying i'm so close up
no that was 97.
that's unlucky
someone should have let me build up first Just a little guy.
No, that guy, I feel like he went fantastic as we're losing
anyway.
I'm just gonna play fantastic.
It felt like that.
It really did.
Look at me go.
I have a...
I live on the 90th floor in my high-rise apartment.
Look at me go.
Alright, now watch this.
Yeah,
and then I made a balcony.
I need you to ult.
Can you get over here?
Wee!
Yay!
I made it!
There you go.
Now I can go back to my...
high-rise apartment yay there you go do we need rocket it
looks cool though what
oh it's fine i don't think you saw my that's right oh he saw
it wait i think he's dead
I don't think he knows.
It's okay.
What?
I don't think they know.
Hey guys!
He don't know!
I'm very...
I think it'll work.
I think it'll work the beacon look we did it the beacon's
too far no it's gonna work guys wait
I did it almost forgot it's too I did it
money and I get Celestia guys oh man like Doki that's so
evil what why don't you guys fund his meal and you guys if
you want fun this meal just just sub here it'll definitely
go towards super Gomez don't worry guys by subbing You would
fund Super Gomez's meal.
That would definitely go straight to him.
We got Celestia.
Yeah, that's wild.
Yay, thank you guys.
It was a super long stream.
We managed to climb on both Overwatch and Bible Rivals
today.
Yeah, and we get to see a really cool concert.
It's a really cool concert today too with Nikkei.
Thank you again to Nikkei for the sponsor.
I had a really nice stream on Twitch today.
I'm going to go head off.
I'm hungry too.
I'm going to walk, dad, get food, and sleep.
And tomorrow, tomorrow, exciting news.
Tomorrow will be the first guest announcement for my
concert.
I'm super excited.
I know, I think it's like a new guest announcement every
three days after that.
So please look forward to it.
There are some guests.
I will say the guests for tomorrow will be singing more than
one song so it's not just one song that she uh she's gonna
appear in uh i was gonna say oh my gosh oh no that's i
spoiled it because i said she but that was like they're all
all the guests are women so oh bet it's coney oh big okay
and we might have scratched coney out of the uh so don't
coney sir women um but anyway uh but other than that thank
you all for watching as uh if you're new here check me on
twitch uh sorry youtube yeah you're like we are already on
twitch check me out on youtube i'm sorry i'm tired now we
streamed for like nine hours now yeah it's almost that it's
eight hours check me out on youtube uh because i That's
where my main platform is.
And you want to know, whenever I stream on Twitch, please
feel free to check me out on Twitter.
I do have a, like I said, if you do exclamation point
concert, I have a concert on July 4th, a 3D concert where
I'll be performing Chibi-Doki and many, many more guests
that will be showing up as well.
It's my first full set list for a concert.
I'm doing like a lot of songs, 10 plus songs, basically.
So please, please check out the concert.
by the area you want to travel it's gonna be very exciting
because it's themed around this uh themed around songs from
2000s to 2010s a lot of variety there's pop punk rock emo
there's so many different types of genres there but uh
they're all very memorable songs from the 2000s to 2010s um
other than that uh but you want to support me with the other
means i do have merch check my merch out and explanation
point merch and also you want to know whenever i stream on
twitch like i said check me on twitter usually i will post a
tweet out whenever i stream on twitch uh as always i
everybody stay hydrated posture check out and move around
get that blood play there's there for me head to bed because
you deserve it thank you for all the subs the bitties the
follows the donations i really appreciate it guys all right
whoa that was a long long spiel hey guys i'll see you guys
next time everybody bye guys bye